Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW. Unsere kleine Welt. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das ist UKW, die siebzigste Ausgabe und die,
fünfundvierzigste Ausgabe von UKW, Corona Weekly, heute am dreiundzwanzigsten April zwanzigeinundzwanzig,
einem Freitag, wie ihr es von uns gewohnt seid, von uns, nämlich Mia, Tim und Pavel natürlich, hallo Pavel.
Hallo Tim, wow. Ja, ganz schön viel geworden irgendwie. Wer hätte das gedacht, äh als wir damals
irgendwie die erste also vor über einem Jahr äh glaube ich die erste Sendung äh gemacht haben, dass wir ein Jahr später irgendwie auf was vierundvierzig
Sendungen zurückblicken können, die wahrscheinlich ja, so langsam an die hundert Stunden ranreichen.
Ja, das kann gut hinhauen, wenn wir sie nicht schon überschritten haben. Ja, so ist das. Äh, denn äh.
Wie heißt es so schön? Ich weiß nicht, ob geil, ob das stimmt, aber ich habe das mal so in einer Signatur eines Freundes von mir. Chinesischer Fluch. Mögest du in interessanten Zeiten leben.
Ja ja.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht muss ich auch sagen, empfinde ich diesen Dialog hier auch sehr als sehr befreiend,
weil man einfach so die äh Möglichkeit, aber auch die Notwendigkeit hat, seine Gedanken so ein bisschen immer wieder äh auszuschütteln und klar zu rücken,
wie man's denn jetzt eigentlich alles so sieht und was man denn eigentlich so sieht. Und das hat schon geholfen, finde ich.
Und das ja und so wie es aussieht äh scheint es aber auch vielen Leuten so zu gehen
das ja sie hier was rausziehen können was sie machen nicht so viele Leute hören aber,
so viele sagen's auch einfach explizit, dass wir ihnen schon ein bisschen Halt gegeben haben und auch durch die
Pandemie geholfen haben. Ich will mich ja jetzt nicht äh oder uns jetzt nicht zu sehr beweihräuchern, sondern nur darauf aufmerksam machen, dass ja ich das schon sehr wohl zur Kenntnis
nehme und mich natürlich auch darüber freue,
Auch wenn es nicht das ist, warum wir irgendwie damit damit angefangen äh haben, äh glaube ich. Ich habe dann auch nochmal
rekapituliert und letztlich immer was tun wir hier oder was tue ich hier? Habe ich so ein bisschen auf den Punkt äh gebracht, äh angefangen habe
weil ich eben oder wir
vor Corona, ich sage mal weder Virologen, noch Corona Experten sind, haben wir uns einfach rangemacht, alles zu lernen und rauszufinden
was es in Corona gibt
und einfach unsere Lernerfahrung äh hier öffentlich gemacht und sind dabei natürlich dann auch immer ein bisschen schon zuversichtlicher geworden, dass das schon Hand und Fuß hat, was wir hier verbreiten. Meistens hier.
Beziehungsweise wenn wir mal so ein bisschen daneben liegen oder uns einschränken müssen, dass dann halt auch immer tun. Und ähm ja, das werden wir sicherlich auch diese Woche wieder tun.
Jeder kann sich täuschen oder Irrtümern äh auf äh sitzen, aber es sollte, man sollte irgendwie schon statistisch gesehen häufiger richtig liegen
als man falsch liegt und wenn man falsch liegt dann eben auch zu gucken dass man natürlich ja daraus daraus lernt um halt die Zukunft nicht so oft falsch zu liegen.
Das ist ähm für mich so das Prinzip auch. Warum wir das machen. Und,
Und natürlich, dadurch, dass wir hier, dass das so öffentlich ist und auch unter Twitter äh und auch auf Twitter
Ja, da ganz viele Leute hier mitlesen und zuhören und äh schon auch und sofort auf Fehler hinweisen oder auf Darstellungen, die nicht so äh in Ordnung waren oder präzise sind oder auf andere Aspekte, die,
ausgelassen, aber ich find's super.
Genau, da kann man an der Stelle auch mal auf eine Sache hinweisen, die ich in den letzten äh Sendungen aufgebracht hatte
dann geht's um diese Oxword-Studie rund um diese Betrachtung mit, na ja, wie viel Hirn
Thrombosen gibt's denn nun eigentlich von Covid und äh wo dann auch dieser Vergleich gezogen wurde zu entsprechenden Fällen von Leuten, die halt
innerhalb von vierzehn Tagen nach der Impfung äh was ähnliches vorweisen konnten, auf Basis der Untersuchung von Patientendaten.
Keine speziell dafür angelegte Studie, sondern ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt, so eine.
Meter Studie beziehungsweise so eine so eine ja.
Ich nicht, kenne den Begriff nicht genau, auf jeden Fall wurde quasi in der Datenbank äh äh geblättert und da gibt's ja dann auch so einige Ungenauigkeiten und ich wurde dann von verschiedenen Seiten darauf hingewiesen, dass.
Vielleicht also dass die aus, also vielleicht kurz zu rekapitulieren. Daraus äh wurde ja so im Prinzip die Betrachtung gemacht, na ja ähm.
Fälle treten halt auch auf von Sinusthrombosen bei Leuten, die eben an Covid erkranken, das war dann so in der Größenordnung von vierzig auf eine Million und äh bei dieserselben Datenbank Durchforstung
kamen dann die Leute aus Oxford für MRNA Geimpfte innerhalb von vierzehn Tagen, die also auch entsprechende,
Sinusthrombosen entwickelt äh haben äh auf die Zahl von vier und auch für wurde dann äh kann man auf die Zahl von fünf das Problem damit ist, dass halt,
Also die Ungenauigkeit hier äh doch relativ groß sein kann.
Ja, weil das ist hat auch viel damit zu tun, wird das eigentlich richtig erfasst, ist wirklich dasselbe gemeint. Das Ganze basiert ja immer auf diesen Schlüssel, Zahlen für medizinische
Einschätzung, ja, dieser ICD.
Die Codes, ja.
Diese Codes und die werden dann auch in jedem Land ein bisschen anders behandelt und das war ja irgendwie USA und die Astrasinika Zahlen kamen dann wiederum aus der Betrachtung, die die EMA gemacht hat in Europa. Also um's kurz zu machen, viele Leute meinten.
Dass sie das, also die da mehr Einblick haben, dass sie jetzt diese.
Dieser diese unmittelbaren Vergleiche so nicht ziehen würden. Was man aber auf jeden Fall stehen lassen kann, ist Sinusthrombosen treten auch auf, wenn Leute an Covid erkranken und das war
Meiner Meinung nach auch so ein bisschen die Kernaussage und äh ich wollte jetzt nicht so sehr drauf rumtrampeln
das jetzt auf jeden Fall MRNA genauso gefährlich ist äh äh wie oder so. Das würde ich sagen, ist immer noch offen. Das wird irgendwie untersucht und.
Dazu habe ich dann einfach erst mal keine Aussage gemacht.
Also äh normal genau die
ähm wichtigste äh wichtigste Ergebnis, ähm ja, Sinus, Wien, Thrombosen sind auch ein mit äh der,
Covid-Erkrankung assoziiertes, sehr seltenes Symptom und
aber um sagen jetzt den
Impfstoffvergleich, also sagen jetzt Schlüsse über verschiedene Impfstoffe zu ziehen, äh reicht halt diese Studie nicht aus. Ich glaube, so kann man's
mal zusammenfassen, außer dass die Impfstoffe halt viel, viel sicherer sind, äh als wenn man erkrankt so Größenordnung ziehen wahrscheinlich.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, gehen wir mal auf unser klassisches äh Segment und schauen mal, was sich denn eigentlich bei den Zahlen so getan hat und wie nah wir denn äh der Apokalypse jetzt schon wieder gekommen sind. Wenn überhaupt.
Im Moment, so sieht es so aus, als wenn sich das Virus nicht so richtig entscheiden kann, äh was es jetzt tun möchte, also seit mehreren Tagen gibt es irgendwie,
seitwärts irgendwie ein minimal auf, minimal runter, liegt seit zwei Tagen bei eins Komma null eins, also sieben Tage Ehrwert passierend auf Publikations
Daten bei den Inzidenzen ja ist immer das Ding RKI Inzidenzen oder
ähm so auf auf Meldedatum oder die Inzidenzen auf Publikationsdatum, wir nehmen lieber die äh auf Publikationsdatum meistens, die.
Jetzt aktuell bei äh hundertfünfundsiebzig äh heute gestern bei hundertdreiundsiebzig und.
Kurz sagen, warum wir die lieber nehmen. Das Problem mit den RKI-Zahlen ist, dass die sich prinzipiell nachträglich immer noch ändern und in der Regel sowieso letzten Endes in Richtung der Publikationszahlen.
Entwickeln, ne? Er ist richtig äh noch eine Erinnerung habe und deswegen äh ist es eigentlich, hat sich das sozusagen gezeigt, dass das so
der solidere Blick in die Zukunft ist, den wir aber jetzt schon haben.
Genau, weil weil nach Meldedatum fallen natürlich die Zahlen in den letzten
beiden Tagen sehr stark und ich sage mal in der in den ein, zwei Wochen sagen die, die
die davor sind, kommen eben auch noch äh Zahlen nach. Das heißt, dass wenn man diese Zahlen grafisch visualisiert, hast du am Ende immer einen Knick nach unten. Äh,
so und äh und das ist dann aber diese Zahl dann auch, die in den sieben Tage
ähm die in den offiziellen sieben Tage Inzidenz äh wird eingeht. Das heißt, ganz viele Leute, die jetzt aber schon gestern eigentlich,
erkrankt sind oder vorgestern gehen halt heute noch gar nicht ein aufgrund von eben Meldeverzögerungen so und die fallen dann,
erstmal unterm Tisch. Die kommen dann natürlich je weiter die Zeit fortschreitet, kommen natürlich alle Fälle auch nach. Das heißt das gleicht sich so ein bisschen eigentlich irgendwann aus, aber wenn man dem.
Ja heute betrachtet hat man da häufiger dann niedrige Inzidenzen je schlechter oder je langsamer die Ämter arbeiten.
Also bleiben wir weiterhin bei den Publikations sieben Tage äh äh wert und ja, hundertfünfundsiebzig sagst du.
Beziehungsweise ja und hundertvierundsechzig äh war äh glaube ich der der offizielle, die offizielle RKI sieben Tage Inzidenz äh gerade, also die einen unter den hundert äh fünfundsechzig.
Also sowas auch.
Ja.
Aber das spielt sowieso keine Rolle, weil ähm dazu kommen wir später noch. Hm, entscheidend wohl in der Regel die Inzidenz auf Landkreise.
Ja. Aber das bedeutet, dass die Zahlen stagnieren derzeit.
Genau. Ja, ja. So, die Zahlen äh stagnieren. Es geht äh äh horizontal weiter und.
Vielleicht ein bisschen.
Interessanter ist, bevor wir in den an den Punkt gehen, was wir glauben oder was ich glaube, wie das weitergehen wird.
Und zwar, was natürlich auch immer hilfreich ist, zu dem Zweck ist dann erstmal den Blick auf die verschiedenen Altersgruppen äh zu werfen,
und da sehen wir für Deutschland halt vor allen Dingen einen ganz starken Anstieg.
Bei der Altersgruppe fünf bis vierzehn, also den im Schulalter im Wesentlichen, da kann man zu der Altersgruppe kann man wahrscheinlich sagen, das sind wirklich Schüler.
Ähm
Ja, ähm plus äh also da, dort liegt bei den Schülern, die deutschlandweite Inzidenz jetzt bei zweihundertsiebenunddreißig, ja, in der Altersgruppe
und höher ist sie dann nur noch in der der fünfzehn bis Vierunddreißigjährigen, also dann ich sage mal, das Partyvolk
Man könnte aber auch sagen, das sind so dann vielleicht die Berufstätigen und die jungen Familien
so in dem Alter und da ist sogar noch ein bisschen höher, nur die liegen bei zweihundertneunundvierzig.
Bundesweit äh ist halt das Geschehen so in in bei null bis vier, also in den Kitas hält sich noch in Grenzen, das ist nur ganz leicht über dem Durchschnitt, bei hundertsiebenundsechzig.
Ist aber auch ähm als einziges äh mit auch angestiegen, wenn auch leichter äh
als das von den Schülern, die halt richtig hochgehen und kompensiert wird das Ganze äh so vor allem durch,
achtzig äh plus und die auch sechzig bis Neunundsiebzigjährigen, achtzig Plus, liegt halt zum Glück jetzt nur bei vierundsiebzig, nur in Anführungsstrichen und
sechzig bis Neunundsiebzigjährigen bei einer Insidenz von hundertzwei, so was halt dann gerade im Moment den den Schnitt.
Drückt. Ja und deswegen.
War halt immer auch so meine Aussage, es hängt eben sehr, sehr viel ab äh beim weiteren Verlauf, was in den Schulen passiert ist, zu sagen, dass das entscheidende und ähm.
Ja, wie das dann äh mit der Notbremse äh zusammenhängt. Das machen wir dann hinterher oder später.
Noch. Hm, ja.
Kurz betonen. Also, Schüler derzeit Deutschland zweihundertsiebenunddreißig und während halt die Inzidenz insgesamt stagniert.
Sieht das in diesem äh Bereich überhaupt nicht so aus, ganz im Gegenteil. Die steigt sehr steil an. Also wir haben da einen extrem.
Anstieg und sonst haben wir einen äh überhaupt nur einen Anstieg bei Kita.
Also es sind eigentlich wirklich nur die Kleinsten, die stark ansteigen und alles andere stagniert und deswegen stagniert es in der Summe.
Ja, man muss auch gucken, die Situation in den, in den Bundesländern sind eben auch so ein bisschen unterschiedlich, also vor allem äh gibt es eben Unterschiede äh zwischen
ja Schülern äh also die Schüler und Kitaalter so in manchen ähm Bundesländern äh dominiert halt die,
null bis Vierjährigen in den meisten, aber tatsächlich äh fünf bis vierzehn, was den Anstieg angeht. Und bei den alten äh geht's äh überall.
Nach unten. Ja.
Gehen wir nochmal kurz auf die Bundesländer.
Genau, also bei den Inzidenzen sind die meisten
Länder, die sagen, ja, bewegen sich auch seitwärts, so wie der Bundesschnitt. Es gibt aber ein paar,
Ausnahmen, wo das anders aussieht, also Thüringen und Sachsen, die halt von einer ganz hohen
von ja die waren irgendwann mal bei zweihundertfünfundsiebzig so ungefähr und sind jetzt auf zweihundertvierundvierzig und zweihunderteinundvierzig
runter. Also, die haben also jetzt eher starke Rückgänge. Hm.
Und dann äh ja Baden-Württemberg zieht halt an ein bisschen, Hessen zieht an und vor allem das Saarland, das zieht halt am krassesten.
An
'ne Modellregion.
Ja, ist ja auch eine Modellregion, genau, also da haben wir äh da äh und auf Saarland, deswegen wollen wir einfach habe ich dann deswegen einfach mal geguckt, was ist denn da eigentlich los im,
Saarland und auch so ein Blick auf die R Werte zeigt,
eben alle so um unter oder um die eins rumliegen bis eins Komma null fünf maximal und das Saarland aber jetzt auf eins Komma eins fünf.
So hochgeschossen.
Ist und dann sagt immer der erste Blick auf die Altersgruppen und da sieht man, dass dann im Saarland so die im Prinzip die jüngere Hälfte der Bevölkerung so von null bis vierunddreißig,
die ziehen halt in die Höhe, aber auch.
Anderen Altersgruppen ziehen an. Also es zieht halt überall an. Ja und.
Also vielleicht noch äh sagen, bevor ich's bevor ich's vergesse, es wird halt gerade oft ins Feld geführt, dass die Anstiege jetzt in,
diesen Alterssegmenten, also Schulen und Kitas jetzt deswegen so in die Höhe gehen wegen der Schnelltests. Dass jetzt halt,
sagen, die Detektionen in den Bereichen verbessert äh wurde und dass halt jetzt ganz viele ähm.
In der Altersgruppe dazukommen, die vorher einfach symptomlos äh nie erfasst worden wären und jetzt durch die.
Das eben dann auch dem äh PCR-Test Regime zugeführt werden.
Und dass das deswegen hochgeht. Und.
Ich halte das also wir haben's ja mehrfach schon mit der Frage beschäftigt, wie viel ist da dran? Hm.
Ich meine, einen Faktor äh äh wäre, dass äh also es kann durchaus ein Faktor sein, aber hm wenn das so ist.
Dann müsste der Effekt sich bald normalisiert haben, das heißt äh weil das ist letztlich eine Änderung im Testregime, Änderung der Vortest Wahrscheinlichkeit, in der in der Altersgruppe. Hm.
Und äh ja, die ist dann aber irgendwann geändert, irgendwann pendelt sich das halt wieder ein, dann verlaufen die Zahlen vielleicht auf einem hohen Niveau, aber ähm
ob die jetzt rauf oder runter gehen, wird dann relativ schnell nach so einer Änderung ähm,
ja, normalisiert sich das und äh ist dann wieder wieder zuverlässig. So. Und hm.
Der Anstieg halt geht jetzt über eine recht,
Zeit schon und ähm ja, wie groß der Faktor ist, äh werden wir sehen, aber ähm ja,
Äh ich
Teil des Anstieges in den Altersgruppen ist schon einfach real und kein Erfassungs-Adefakt und ist vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben, aber
in ein, zwei, drei Wochen werden wir halt genauer sehen. Normalerweise korrespondiert das Ganze ganz gut mit den Schulschließungen,
Noch eine weitere Besonderheit am Saarland, was mir so nicht.
Bei anderen Ländern nicht aufgefallen ist, wo ja auch keine aber keine Antwort drauf habe, ist, dass im Saarland
Ostern die Zahlen kaum eingebrochen. Sind also ein bisschen auch in äh interessanterweise bei den Schülern und also bei den meisten Altersgruppen, aber in manchen Altersgruppen eben,
Gar nicht. Zum Beispiel äh ja eben null bis vier hat.
Ist durch Ostern ja nicht nicht wesentlich beeinflusst äh worden. Nur halt danach.
Ja und insofern äh ja, plus das eben im Saarland äh die Tests alleine ist auch nicht sein können, weil eben in vier anderen Altersgruppen die Zahlen auch hochgehen. Also ich würde mal sagen, ja.
Testversuch läuft jetzt nicht ganz so gut.
Und ähm ja, beziehungsweise ja, kommt bei dem Test grade raus, äh.
Ja, was eben rauskommen sollte. Und ähnlich auch auf ein kleineres Bundesland guckt, äh Berlin zum Vergleich.
Äh sieht es erstmal auf den ersten Blick ähnlich äh aus, aber in Berlin.
Sind halt die Schülerinzidenzen äh dann auch bei zweihundertzweiundvierzig und dann kommt eben die fünfzehn bis vierunddreißig Jährigen so,
Jugendlichen, junge Familien. Der liegt bei zweihundertneun und äh die Kitas äh tatsächlich liegen ähm sind.
Bei hundertsechsundvierzig, also eher unterdurchschnittlich und vor allem erfreulich,
bei achtzig plus ist die Inzidenz auf sechsunddreißig äh runter. So das äh nimmt da schon mal ganz, ganz gute.
Ähm Level an äh würde ich sagen. Ja äh das zum Vergleich dann mit,
Berlin lohnt sich also dann mal anzuschauen, weil ich dann gerade bei Berlin war. Wir hatten auch lange keinen Blick mehr auf die Berliner Bezirke und dann dachte ich mir äh,
ja, da müssen wir noch ähm irgendwie auch mal einen Blick drauf werfen und.
Ja. Äh ein fast vertrautes Bild Neukölln und Mitte ganz oben mit zweihundertfünfzehn und zweihundertelfer Inzidenzen.
Und dann äh gibt es so langsam äh runter und ganz.
Bester Bezirk unser äh Berlin-Pankow so mit.
Sechsundneunziger Inzidenz. Ich meine, natürlich ist das jetzt, ich sage mal, sehr grob. Ich meine, ich wohne zweihundert Meter von Mitte entfernt, also.
Aber die Meterebene ist ja auch in Pankow und von daher äh.
Ja
Ebene stabil, pankostabil.
Ja, alles alles gut, ja. Und äh generell äh so.
Leute unseren Podcast, das ist wahrscheinlich.
Genau. So wird äh sein und natürlich aber äh räumen wir jetzt ein Jahr lang immer das Auf und Ab der der Bezirke beobachten wie das,
ja aussieht, das heißt so 'ne Momentaufnahme ist dann immer nicht sehr aussagekräftig, weshalb ich denn mal einfach,
von allen Bezirken mir den Gesamtverlauf, also die kommunativen,
ähm zahlen angeguckt habe und
dann auch die Frage, ja ist denn sagen diese Pandemie wie Schicksalhaft, ist es denn so? Wie wie ist es denn, wenn ein Bezirk erstmal auf einer Dreiektorie ist, so gelingt es dann.
Sich sich rauf oder runter zu arbeiten und.
Man muss sagen, überwiegend nicht. Also es gibt immer wieder hier und da Ausnahmen, aber äh zum Beispiel Neukölln und Mitte, wenn man sich anguckt,
sind von dann zumindest äh ja äh ab der,
ab Oktober als dann die dritte Welle äh begonnen hat, sind die halt ja, als.
Führer äh ins Rennen gegangen und sind heute beide immer noch in Führung und haben sich da nicht viel genommen, also mal liegt der einen Ticken vorne und mal der andere und äh dort.
Haben sich halt jetzt so fünf Komma sechs Prozent der Bevölkerung in Neukölln
bereits mit Corona äh infiziert, also fünf Komma sechs sieben drei und in Mitte sind's fünf Komma sechs zwo eins Prozent, also wie man sieht ganz nah beieinander. Der
einzige Bezirk, der es so ein bisschen geschafft hat, sich zu verbessern in der Platzierung. Ist halt Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg. Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendwann Vernunft eingekehrt ist oder was da passiert ist,
aber äh der hat halt äh ja mit mit.
Irgendwie Spandau, was sagen wieder der andere, ist das Negativbeispiel ist, Spandau,
ist halt relativ gut im unteren Drittel des des Feldes im November ins Rennen gegangen und,
ist jetzt äh so auf Platz drei, was so Opfer äh angeht, fünf Komma eins Prozent ähm
also mit Opfern meine ich jetzt ja Erkrankte an an der Stelle. Ja und dann geht's eben wie gesagt weiter Reinickendorf, Friedrichshain, Kreuzberg, äh Berlin,
Tempelhof Charlottenburg-Filmersdorf, äh da sind wir dann ungefähr,
jetzt schon im unteren Mittelfeld angekommen. Ähm dann Stieglitz Zehlendorf und dann,
Lichtenberg Marzahn,
Pankow und Tripto Köpenick, was daneben auch auffällt, ist, dass nicht alle, aber ein Großteil, wenn man der Rhein-Ost-Bezirk äh Lichtenberg ausgenommen so,
am besten durchgekommen sind
und der Unterschied ist sieben, ja, dreieinhalb Prozent jetzt in äh äh Treptow und äh drei Komma vier, eins drei und drei Komma vier neun drei in.
Pankow äh Prozent, die bisher erkrankt sind gegenüber dem fünf Komma sechs, das ist nicht ganz,
so sieht es halt eigentlich in einer Stadt in den verschiedenen Bezirken,
aus und dann,
kam bei mir spontan die Frage auch auf der Tour auf, okay, wie sieht's denn jetzt in den Bundesländern eigentlich aus? Wie gut haben denn jetzt die Bundesländer eigentlich ihre.
Bevölkerung bisher schützen können. Ähm ja.
Und da klafft es halt doch nochmal beziehungsweise äh dann,
auch nicht nur nicht vor Infektionen, sondern vor allen Dingen, wie viele in der Altersgruppe achtzig plus.
Sind dort jetzt gestorben, um ebenso Effekte zu vermeiden, wie naja, dort haben sich mehr ältere infiziert, dort mehr jüngere, weil eventuell ist dann auch mehr ältere oder weniger jüngere,
und äh deswegen ja äh natürlich ist auch die Altersgruppe achtzig plus nicht so homogen in den Ländern, aber auf jeden Fall äh kriegt man so ein klareres Bild und.
Ja, was die Toten äh angeht. Ähm geht es so Faktor drei, dreieinhalb auseinander. Also in Mecklenburg,
Vorpommern sind null Komma vier neun Prozent der über Achtzigjährigen gestorben, also ein halbes Prozent
in Sachsen am anderen Ende eins Komma acht Prozent der älteren Bevölkerung, also es ist halt schon krass und ja,
und das ist das mit großem Abstand, Thüringen folgt dann so mit eins Komma fünf Prozent und Brandenburg mit eins Komma zwei Prozent und.
Das ist quasi jeder jeder Fünfzigste fast. Jeder Fünfzigste aus der Gruppe der achtzig plus.
Jeder fünfundfünfzigste.
Nicht nicht erkrankt, sondern gestorben.
Gestorben, ja. Genau. Jeder fünfundfünfzigste werden's halt dann in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern.
Und Sachsen ist relativ gut gestartet, ne? Also im November waren sie noch im Mittelfeld und sind dann im Laufe des Dezember.
Komplett äh in die Führung gegangen und haben diese Führung auch nicht mehr abgegeben und ähnlich mit ein bisschen mehr Verzögerung war's dann in Thüringen,
Und Thüringen ist dann ganz klar auf Platz zwei mit eins Komma fünf Prozent und dann ist wieder ein großer Abstand, bis dann die anderen Länder sich so hintereinander einreihen.
Also beide Länder sind tatsächlich irgendwie gut gestartet und man kann schön sagen aus aus den äh Zahlen, also Sachsen hat's schon
im November im Prinzip verbockt, also Ende November, was auch immer da passiert ist, so mag auch Einschleppungen aus Tschechien sein, aber das hat halt da ziemlich früh äh abgehoben
und ja, wie du richtig sagst, in Thüringen, die äh sind dann erstmal etwas später, eigentlich so richtig erst im neuen Jahr eigentlich erst nach Weihnachten, also Thüringen hat's eigentlich erst äh sagen, im Januar so richtig
verbockt, äh kann man sagen, oder je nachdem äh wie man das sieht, ähm ja und,
Sachsen-Anhalt auch noch so ein Beispiel. Die sind halt ganz unten gewesen, sind halt als zweitbestes Land mit irgendwie kaum Toten
in die äh in den Dezember äh gegangen und äh sind jetzt ja im Mittelfeld angekommen mit mit einem
Prozent ungefähr.
Brandenburg ist es nicht sehr wie anders gelaufen. Also man kann sogar sagen, wirklich die großen Flächenländer im Osten haben dann.
Ich würde es jetzt mal deuten als sich ein wenig in Sicherheit gewogen und da sie ja in der ersten Welle nicht so betroffen waren und das ist ja, sagen wir mal generell das, was sich so zeigt und was ja eigentlich auch.
Von der Wissenschaft ausreichend vorher gesagt wurde
Virus sich erstmal heimisch gemacht hat, wenn sie sich erstmal verbreitet hat, wenn's überall irgendwo reingestreut ist und es eben nicht mehr diese
Schwerpunkte gibt, die es ja am Anfang durch die äh initiale Infektionen gab, ne, Nordrhein-Westfalen war stark betroffen, Bayern war stark betroffen,
Baden-Württemberg war starr betroffen und der Osten heilt nicht so stark. Und dann hat sich das im Sommer alles schön durchmischt.
Und als dann die zweite Welle kam, geht's richtig ab. Und dann sind natürlich auch die entsprechenden.
Reaktionen dann langsamer, weil man denkt so, na ja, wieso nutzt man auch nix passiert, dann wird das auch wieder so sein. Und genau das zeigen halt die Zahlen, dass das eben ein Trugschluss ist und dann steht man auf einmal in der Statistik ganz oben.
Bayern ist vielleicht auch nur mal wieder ein gutes Beispiel, die sind halt absolut
in Führung gestartet mit den meisten Toten nach der ersten Welle und äh nach dem Sommer mit einer Inzidenz, die ja zäh, also,
zehn, fünfzehn Mal so hoch war, also jetzt sagen gesamte äh kommulative Zahl der der Todesfälle
und haben sich aber dann ja in diesem Jahr und über Weihnachten, aber vor allem ja eigentlich in diesem Jahr recht gut geschlagen, was auch immer sie gemacht haben. So äh,
im neuen Jahr oder oder ab Weihnachten oder so, das hat auf jeden Fall dazu geführt, dass sie jetzt
nur noch auf Platz fünf sind und äh sagen, bei kumulierte Zahl der Achtzigjährigen und ja, also
Bayern zumindest muss man sagen, die haben äh.
Irgendwas geändert oder sie hatten vielleicht auch Glück, äh Hunos, aber äh ja äh das kommt natürlich auch, aber zumindest äh,
Ja, würde ich, würde ich sagen, das ist nicht von alleine äh passiert, sondern da muss da war irgendwie was. Ja.
Ähm so und dann vielleicht nochmal, okay, das war jetzt quasi achtzig Plus
Jetzt kann man sagen, gut, das vielleicht
haben die auch eine andere Altersstruktur dann bei achtzig Plus und andere Arten von Unterbringung und weiß der Geier was. Und deswegen dachte ich mir lohnt sich's vielleicht auch den Vergleich für eine andere
Altersgruppe äh zu machen und bei,
siebzig äh äh bei bei fünfundsechzig bis sechzig bis neunundsiebzig. So. Bei sechzig bis neunundsiebzig sieht es genauso,
aus äh im Wesentlichen, wie bei bei achtzig Plus. Hm.
Bei so fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzig, also die Todesfälle dort, die jetzt nicht so super viele.
Sind, aber sozusagen die Altersgruppe, wo man noch ein bisschen Statistik machen kann, so.
Es sieht die Durchmischung dann schon wieder äh äh teilweise recht anders aus, wobei interessanterweise das Ende der Tabelle und äh sagen die Top
in der Tabelle sind identisch, aber äh so dann ja
dazwischen äh sieht's halt ganz anders aus, also zum Beispiel Bremen, dass ich halt bei den Achtzigjährigen extrem gut geschlagen hat
steht halt bei den fünfunddreißig bis Neunundfünfzigjährigen irgendwie eher auf auf Platz vier und so weiter. Also,
anderen Worten ähm man kann das jetzt nicht auf alle Altersgruppen übertragen, sondern äh da gibt es eben.
Ganz ganz äh andere.
Dinge und dann bei den jüngeren kommen halt die Todesfälle nicht sehen, aber da lohnt es sich zumindest einfach die Fallzahlen zu betrachten und da ist dann die Frage, Dan, wer hat denn jetzt seine Schüler.
Am meisten durchseucht äh bisher, während der drei Wellen. Ja und da,
findet man dann interessanterweise, dass Bayern, Berlin, Saarland und dann erst Sachsen und Thüringen äh kommen, was jetzt so das Schüleralter äh angeht,
ja, also das sind dann sagen die,
die, wo die Schulen am meisten durchseucht sind und dann geht's halt runter und ja, Schleswig-Holstein findet sich halt meistens ganz, ganz unten
und in dem Fall auch Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und Brandenburg interessanterweise ist auch äh Dritte von unten, also während's bei den Alten halt,
ganz schlecht aussah. Und wenn man schon dabei sind, können wir auch gucken, so wie es denn mit den null bis Vierjährigen,
und äh da sind's dann wiederum äh ja das Saarland, Thüringen, Bayern und NRW.
Und dann noch Sachsen-Anhalt, die so oben stehen, aber die Unterschiede sind dann auch tatsächlich nicht so groß, also die sind so Faktor zwei, inzwischen jetzt Saarland und Schleswig-Holstein und die meisten tummeln sich da,
Mittelfeld ja, also bestes eins Komma fünf Prozent, also Schleswig-Holstein und drei Prozent ist äh Saarland, was die durch Infektions äh Rate der der Kleinsten.
Angeht und nachdem ich jetzt gesehen hatte.
Wie weit so die Bundesländer in den Werten auseinanderliegen, kam natürlich die Frage, okay, wie extrem,
gibt es denn jetzt in den Landkreisen zu? Wie extrem ist äh sind dort die Unterschiede und habe mir dann.
Erstmal die für achtzig plus tödlichsten Landkreise ausgesucht und die fünf,
glücklichsten äh Landkreise so bezogen auf die Gesamtzahl der Todesfälle bei achtzig Plus. Und da findet man dann so in den Top five halt den bekannten,
Landkreis Tirschenreuth aus Bayern, dann sächsische Schweiz Ostergebirge, Hiltburghausen,
Schwabach und Görlitz. Das sind sozusagen die fünf Landkreise, wo ja der Großteil der.
Älteren Bevölkerung an Corona gestorben ist oder der größte Teil, nicht der Großteil, also so und.
Größten Anteil hatten.
Größten Anteil, genau. Und äh in sind es drei Komma eins Prozent der.
Achtzig plus jährigen. Also man kann sagen, jeder Dreißigstel in Tirschenreuth, äh der über achtzig war, ist Corona zum Opfer gefallen. Das finde ich halt schon.
Sehr, sehr krass.
Und am anderen Ende der Skala ja sind wir jetzt äh finden wir zwei Brückenkreis Zweibrücken ähm
als extrem Ausreißer mit nur
achtunddreißig Fällen pro hunderttausend, was halt null Komma null drei acht äh Prozent sind äh gegenüber eben drei Komma eins,
Prozent bei Türschenreuth und dann äh geht's weiter Rostock null Komma ein Prozent.
Ne? Und äh ja, also Faktor hundert zwischen den.
Ja Landkreisen mit den wenigsten alten äh äh Toten pro Bevölkerung und den am meisten. So und dann,
stellt sich natürlich die Frage, okay, lag das jetzt.
Einfach nur an den hohen.
Äh die da vorherrschten oder.
Sind die Altersgruppen speziell geschützt worden oder besser geschützt worden, das sozusagen die Frage, ne?
Ja, zum einen sind, genau, sind die Altersgruppen besser geschützt worden, aber gibt es dort auch Unterschiede jetzt in der äh Sterblichkeit, in der in der Fall.
Sterblichkeit und äh ja, ein erster Blick erstmal dann auf die auf die Fälle, wenn man da dieselben Landkreise jetzt nimmt und mal guckt.
Wie sich denn dort die Inzidenzen verteilen. Kann man schon mal sehen, das ist halt zwischen zwei Brücken und dann Fürth als äh höchsten.
Landkreis sieht man, dass das längst nicht so weit auseinander liegt wie dann jetzt die Zahl der Toten. Also da.
Auf jeden Fall nochmal einen krasser Faktor rein und hm ja, wenn man sich dann eben auch die Fallsterblichkeiten äh anguckt.
In diesen Landkreisen sieht man aber auch, dass die.
Halt sehr stark variieren, also Fallsterblichkeit oder äh ja CFR oder Ratio ist einfach die.
Zahl der hm.
Todesfälle geteilt durch die Zahl der Fälle, also wie viele,
jetzt von denen, die positiv getestet wurden, eigentlich gestorben sind. Und das auch wieder.
Auf die Altersgruppe achtzig plus und.
Da sieht man, dass man jetzt in Zweibrücken, wenn man in zwei Brück.
Positiven Test bekommen hat als über Achtzigjähriger.
Dann sind vier Prozent von denen gestorben. In Dillingen äh dagegen,
so äh jetzt sind dreiunddreißig Prozent, also jeder dritte oder in Schwabach auch so, das heißt,
Ja, es gibt da merkwürdigerweise auch so.
Riesige Unterschiede ähm in äh der Fallsterblichkeit selbst.
Einer Altersgruppe. Das kann natürlich auch wieder daran liegen, dass sich diese Altersgruppe achtzig Plus dort unterschiedlich zusammensetzt.
Aber so ganz äh so erschließt sich mir das noch nicht. Natürlich kann man auch erwarten, wenn.
Du jetzt einfach nur das auswürfeln würdest, so welcher Bezirk kriegt jetzt wie viel Corona eigentlich dann
würdest du auch durch mehr oder weniger Zufall würdest du natürlich auch eine Verteilung,
so und am sogenannten Long-Tail. Vielleicht findest du dann auch einige wenige extremen Fälle.
Und auf die gucken wir hier grade. Und äh.
Bin dann auf das Phänomen dann erst gestoßen durch dieses Stöbern und habe das jetzt noch nicht tiefer untersucht und äh habe dann auch zwar gefragt, ob jemand Ideen hat im Netz, hm.
Was denn dahinter steckt äh und es ist aber auf jeden Fall, finde ich, durchaus äh nochmal eine.
Forschungsrichtung, die es wert ist, sich anzuschauen, was sind die Ursachen dafür, dass in manchen Landkreisen sehr viele alte äh gestorben sind und in anderen vergleichsweise wenig.
Von denen, die sich überhaupt infiziert haben. Wohlgemerkt, ne? Also nicht äh anteilig, das hatten wir am Anfang, sondern dieser Block war ja jetzt nochmal spezifisch, okay, wir schauen uns immer nur an, okay, Leute über achtzig haben sich infiziert,
Was passiert mit denen? Und in Zweibrücken sterben vier Prozent von denen? Aber in Dillingen.
Sterben dreiunddreißig Prozent davon. Also anders ausgedrückt in Dillingen.
Wenn man achtzig war und überhaupt infiziert war.
Jeder Dritte stirbt. Das ist schon ein krasses Missverhältnis.
Und gut, ich habe dann äh dort halt,
auch den, den Bundesschnitt mit drin, der liegt halt jetzt.
Bei zwanzig Prozent. Das heißt, äh jetzt in.
Dillingen mit den dreiunddreißig A ist halt äh immerhin auch sechzig Prozent äh höher, aber äh krasser sind halt dann äh waren ganz unten,
die äh Bezirke und eins, was dabei aber auffällt, ist, dass die meisten davon so eher kleine Landkreise sind, so mit fünfzigtausend Einwohnern,
Das heißt.
Es könnte jetzt sein, äh dass das auch irgendwelche strukturellen äh Gründe hat, was weiß ich, ob da, wie das Gesundheitsamt ist und ob das arbeitet und ob das vielleicht keine Ahnung
mit anderen Landkreisen zusammengelegt ist und es dadurch vielleicht irgendwie
erfassungsartifakte sind oder ganz besondere äh äh Dinge und es kann natürlich auch ja Besonderheiten in der Bevölkerungsstruktur oder in den Wohnverhältnissen oder so,
Punkt ist, äh dass es sich, wie ich finde, auf jeden Fall um eine äh nochmal einen interessanten
Punkt handelt, der noch unzureichend äh aufgeklärt ist und der uns natürlich vielleicht auch helfen kann oder anderen helfen könnte, wenn die dort irgendwas anders oder besser gemacht äh haben und das eben nicht zufällig äh ist, also,
Ich hoffe, dass da auch Leute dran sind. Ähm ja, gut, ich glaube, äh.
Ja, wir könnten jetzt noch, ich habe dann noch auch Vergleiche gemacht ähm mit noch anderen niedrigen äh.
Kumulierten äh Fällen beispielsweise mir noch mal angeguckt und.
Es ist ist halt äh schon so, dass man jetzt als Regelfähig draus ziehen kann. Okay, es gibt einfach bestimmte.
Landkreise, da hebt Covid nicht ab. So, die sind halt dann von Anfang niedrig und die hat's halt nie so richtig erwischt in bestimmten Altersgruppen.
Und andere, da geht's eben richtig.
Und viermal so viel äh so,
Ja, insofern und warum das so ist und ob da mehr als Zufall äh eine Rolle spielt, das äh denke ich äh ja, da werden wir vielleicht in Zukunft.
Nochmal mehr ein Auge draufhalten.
Erforschen.
Aber man muss ja überhaupt erstmal solche Artefakte äh finden, um sich dann irgendwie die Frage stellen zu können, was ist denn hier los? Und ich bin mir sicher, äh die Statistiker sind jetzt schon unterwegs, versuchen herauszufinden, was damit jetzt wieder auf sich hat.
UK wieder aufgedeckt hat. Skandal.
Okay, das sind jetzt die Zahlen, wie sie sich uns äh darstellen und das sind sagen wir mal so die der aktuelle Blick nach hinten, aber was ja auch schon mal den Blick nach vorne gewagt und kühne Aussagen über die Zukunft gemacht.
Jetzt kommen dann alle an und halten dir die alten Tweets vor die Nase und sagen Mensch Pavel, was.
Genau, wo ist denn die zweihunderter Inzidenz geblieben oder die fünfhunderter, wie ich in einem ersten,
März äh vorher äh gesagt habe, in Anführungszeichen und ähm ja.
Daten und da ist es so, dass eben jetzt diese Woche oder in der letzten Woche so ein bisschen.
Ja so 'ne Prognosenkontroverse entbrannt ist, also es war jetzt nicht nur nicht nur ich, aber ich kriegte dann halt wieder auch.
Gehäuft so äh ähm,
etwas chemische Nachfragen, ja, wo ist denn jetzt, wo sind denn jetzt deine zweihundert und was sollte das denn jetzt mit der Panik und so? Und,
ähm ja äh und
Das äh war dann aber nicht nur sagen etwas, was an mich gerichtet war, sondern an viele andere äh ja prominentere
Prognosen, die dann auch äh letztlich äh Grundlage waren
ein bisschen für die, für die Maßnahmen zumindest Ansatz äh weise, also für jetzt die Bundesnotbremse und da wurde also dann
ganz vielen Leuten äh jetzt von einer bestimmten Richtung halt.
Panikmache vorgeworfen. Und ähm.
Ja. Äh so und ich hatte mich daneben auch dazu geäußert, obwohl.
Ich zwar einerseits ja glaube ich kann das jeder selber sehen, was ich äh vorher,
gesagt habe und ich fand's eigentlich auch ein bisschen kindisch äh so, ehrlich gesagt,
äh was da,
los war, weil gut, erstmal, wenn man sich anguckt, gut, was habe ich denn sozusagen in Anführungszeichen vorhergesagt. Ich habe halt in einem spontanen,
Tweet, wo ich dann ganz mal einfach im im Kopf äh gerechnet hatte, habe ich halt,
getwittert, also vor allen Dingen eine Frage an Zero Covid-Gegner. In vier Wochen wird die Inzidenz deutschlandweit über zweihundert liegen. In,
acht Wochen über fünfhundert pro hunderttausend, also mehr als sechzigtausend Neuinfektionen pro Tag. Was genau ist euer Vorschlag.
Und äh ich habe das dann hinterher nochmal in dem äh Tweet äh in dem Sweat nochmal ein bisschen klar gesagt, dass ich also nicht mit dem fünfhundert rechne, sondern dass ich davon ausgehe, dass halt durch verschiedene Faktoren.
Unter anderem aber durch die Reaktion, wenn die hochgeht wir einen Lockdown benötigen, bevor wir die fünfhundert erreichen, so das heißt äh natürlich waren die.
Alle vor dem Hintergrund, wenn jetzt nichts passiert.
Und äh so und was ist denn äh passiert? Das habe ich jetzt auch nochmal geguckt, so wie wie sehr ich denn.
Daneben gelegen habe und da habe ich leider nicht genug daneben.
Gelegen, sondern ähm ja, ich habe halt äh im Prinzip äh.
Steigerung, also um den Faktor äh Steigerung drei prognostiziert, also dass sich das sich innerhalb von vier Wochen.
Jetzt die Inzidenzen verdreifachen äh werden und äh sie haben sich dann äh hatten sich dann erstmal nur Moment, wo haben wir's? Ähm.
Ja irgendwie zwei Komma dreifacht und dann.
Nochmal äh bis bis heute, Jahrfer, ich glaube zwei Komma sechs facht. Äh ja.
Und ich finde, ja, ich hätte lieber gerne mehr falsch gelegen und.
Ich habe das äh eben auch zu einem Zeitpunkt so prognostiziert, das muss man auch.
Dazusehen, wo die Zahlen äh nur sehr flach äh äh noch anstiegen.
Und zu sagen ist eigentlich den, wenn man jetzt nur auf die Zahlen geguckt hätte, auf die reine.
Bewegung auf die Inzidenzentwicklung war da nix exponentielles äh zu dem Zeitpunkt, sondern so ein langsamer, linearer Anstieg am ersten März und es ging dann eben aber verspätet erst ab.
Womit ich ehrlich gesagt auch nicht gerechnet hatte bei der Prognose,
war Ostern, das über Ostern die Schulen zu sind und andere Dinge äh äh passieren, so den Effekt hatte ich gar nicht berücksichtigt, bei allem wie sagt man? Ich hatte das mehr oder weniger auch im Kopf gerechnet.
So und,
ja und dann eben wurde aber, weil.
Anderen Prognosen sahen halt genau so oder sogar noch höher aus, also die, ich sage mal, seriösen äh Prognosen, die dann auch äh wirklich komplexe Modelle.
Dahinter hatten und so kamen dann aber hm, genau zu den selben Ergebnissen, wie ich im im Kopf und.
Wurden dann jetzt auch jetzt angegangen so mit ja und äh ihr habt ja unnötig Panik gemacht und der Sommer macht jetzt alles weg.
Und ganze Lockdown ist Quatsch, so diese ganze,
Ecke so und ihr habt uns belogen und äh irgendwie unnötig Panik geschürt und ich meine,
erschließt sich zwar auch nicht, wer denn jetzt wirklich interessiert sein könnte daran. Irgendwie Panik zu schüren und damit uns mit Lockdowns zu
quälen so, also diese
diese Verschwörungsgeschichte macht nun so überhaupt gar keinen Sinn. Also das das konnte ich halt jetzt noch nicht ergründen. Ähm.
Ja. Hm. Und äh da kann man aber am Ende des Tages äh nur.
Sagen, ähm ja, es ist ein bisschen Präventionsparadoxon und äh,
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo man eben Prognosen macht, dass das schlimm wird, wird's halt weniger schlimm.
Weil alle Leute wissen, oh, jetzt wird's schlimm. Äh und passen halt, äh, das haben wir halt auch.
Mehrfach eigentlich bei bei jedem Lockdown gesehen, dass meistens auch Lockdowns,
eine Folge waren von auch so einer Beunruhigung, die erst in der Bevölkerung ausging und dann
anschließend auch die Politik erfasste und die hat dann reagiert
Und dann ähm konnte man aber sehen, dass meistens äh zeitgleich mit dem Inkrafttreten des Lockdowns die Zahlen schon
Anfingen zu sinken, obwohl die eigentlich zehn Tage.
Zurückliegen, das heißt meistens eben sagt, passiert das eben vorher und unabhängig und ein Teil der Leute.
Reagiert einfach auf Zahlen und vermutlich.
Spekuliert die Deutschen sind halt ein sensibles Völkchen oder ein großer Teil davon und die gucken sich halt an Inzidenz irgendwie so, ne, denn vielleicht mal nicht.
So oder dann setze ich mir halt jetzt die Maske schon mal ein bisschen früher auf und nehme sie ein bisschen später.
Äh oder trage eben auch eine Maske, wenn ich mal einen Freund nur kurz besuche. So, nehme die dann nicht ab. So solche kleinen Dinge passieren dann äh halt. Ja und.
Ähm was aber auch noch eine Rolle spielt, was ich glaube, ist, dass äh B eins eins sieben in der Infektion so ein bisschen
überschätzt äh wurde. Ich glaube, da haben viele auch mit vierzig, fünfzig, sechzig Prozent höherer Infektisität
äh geredet oder sind davon ausgegangen, für ihre Modelle. Ich bin halt dann aus den englischen Zahlen,
eher auf dreißig Prozent im Durchschnitt gekommen und vierzig Prozent nur bei den Kindern. So.
Das heißt, äh da hatten viele Modelle meiner Meinung nach auch ein bisschen äh äh zu hohen Faktor drin. Das kam eben auch noch. Ja.
Aber so die entscheidende Frage natürlich, ich habe mich dann auch gefragt, oh, warum kommen die jetzt alle aus.
Ihren Löchern äh vorgekrochen, weil ist ja jetzt gar nicht noch, war ja jetzt noch gar nicht.
Ende April wirklich so, da ist ja noch ein bisschen hin und die haben sich halt alle in Twitter-Wecker gestellt, so remint me in four oder at weeks oder wie auch immer. Aber die Zeit war eben noch nicht abgelaufen.
Und ja, dann ist mir aufgefallen, der eigentliche Punkt ist.
Dass äh jetzt weil die Zahlen eben nicht so explodiert sind, jetzt eine ganze Reihe Morgenluft wittern und jetzt wieder sagen, aha, sieht er, haben wir doch recht gehabt. Der Sommer kommt, es wird wärmer und die Zahlen gehen runter,
So und ihr habt uns alle totalen Quatsch erzählt, äh dass jetzt die Zahlen hochgehen und wir hätten eigentlich gar nichts tun müssen und lass uns das doch jetzt mal mit den ganzen Lockdownquatsch äh einfach,
sein lassen. So und ja letztlich.
Wie es weitergeht ist halt noch immer nicht entschieden. Ich hoffe, dass uns ein weiterer Anstieg erspart.
Also wir haben gerade schon so ein bisschen die Chance und auch das Potential.
Den Trend umzukehren und ich habe auch jetzt seit ein oder zwei oder,
seit Wochen äh äh sage ich, der weitere Trend hängt massiv davon ab, äh ob Schulen aufbleiben oder schließen. Das ist so ein entscheidender Faktor und.
Im Moment kommt es tatsächlich zu Schulschließungen auch in einem.
Mindestens ein Drittel der Landkreise kann man sagen, ist das die die Folge,
Also äh die, ich meine, sonst würden sich halt die Leute auch nicht drüber aufregen über die Notbremse, wenn die Notbremse jetzt nicht mh.
Bestimmte Dinge nicht mehr erlauben würde, die sich die Länder halt rausgenommen haben. Aber Schlupflöcher gibt's natürlich trotzdem äh jede Menge.
So in dem Ding, großartig auch wieder, wie sie das dies Ausgeh-Verbot äh oder die nächtlichen Ausgangssperren,
konstruiert haben, so bis Mitternacht gilt dann nochmal eine Ausgangssperre leit,
wo du dann trotzdem einfach rausgehen kannst, aber es ist halt, du darfst dann irgendwie nicht mit anderen Leuten rumlaufen und du darfst auch nicht joggen
dabei glaube ich dann nach weiß ich glaube so ein Joggingverbot nach einundzwanzig Uhr jetzt und ja.
Okay, also jetzt jetzt sind wir sozusagen voll im Thema, ne? Also dann machen
doch mal äh äh sozusagen von diesen äh Zahlen, äh wie sie sich dargestellt haben, so wie sie sich nicht dargestellt haben, zu was wir uns denn jetzt äh an an Maßnahmen neu haben einfallen lassen.
Und äh jetzt ist sie also in Kraft, diese tolle Bundesnotbremse, was für ein Name, ja, ähm nach einem,
wochenlangen Hickhack. Also ich glaube, diese Ansage, dass ich Frau Merkel das irgendwie nur zwei Wochen anschaut, ist das jetzt drei oder vier Wochen, nee, ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz.
Mhm. Äh.
Zeit verstreicht und da war schon irgendwie gefühlt alles viel zu spät und Wochen und Monate, nachdem man irgendwie überhaupt mal wieder das Richtige hätte tun können und meine gut, wir haben ohnehin, glaube ich, also ich zumindest, äh
eh die Hoffnung aufgegeben, dass noch irgendwelche Maßnahmen ergriffen werden, die wirklich nennenswert irgendwas verbessern. Da lass ich mich auch gerne eines Besseren belehren.
Aber jetzt äh haben wir halt diese Bundesnotbremse und ehrlich gesagt, du kannst mir jetzt mal erklären, was da eigentlich beschlossen wurde, weil ich habe mich irgendwie aus diesem.
Prozess schon rausgeht.
Ja, es ist auch wieder sagen, ähm es ist,
unübersichtlich, so kann man sagen und äh so. Aber versuchen wir es äh einfach mal.
Es gibt da,
zwei Inzidenzgrenzen so. Einmal gibt es halt die Inzidenzgrenze einhundert, also sieben Tage Inzidenz über einhundert.
Und also warten unter hundert können die Bundesländer erstmal
machen so, ich sage mal im Wesentlichen, was sie wollen. Auch nicht ganz, aber ich sage mal, die Bundesnotbremse setzt halt erst bei über hundert ein.
Also sie können dann auf jeden Fall genug tun, um auch schnell wieder über hundert zu kommen.
Genau, das das auch, ja, problemlos. So. Ähm so und da gibt's dann eben erstmal eine Einschränkung,
für private Kontakte, so darf's jetzt maximal eine weitere Person zu dir
gleichzeitig nach Hause reinlassen, also
zwei Personen ist nicht. Wiederum ja bestimmte Ausnahmen dann wieder für Kinder, also die zählen dann eben nicht als eigenständige Person äh bei diesen privaten Kontakten, also man kann dann auch.
Ja, keine Ahnung, Freundin mit ihrem Kind oder so, kann dann.
Oder einen Kindergeburtstag.
Ja. Kleinen Kindergeburtstag, ja, mit äh.
Sind ja nur Kinder.
Genau.
Soll da schon passieren?
Ja. Ähm.
So, aber es müssen dann Verwandte, Kinder. Also wenn also du kannst dann Kindergeburtstag wahrscheinlich äh mit äh einer Familie feiern äh so sagen, wo, also mit dem gesamten Geschwistern.
Gut, die Einschränkungen gibt's. Gut, dann äh nehme ich das zurück, weil immer ein Witz.
Ja, genau. So, äh, ah und äh sehe gerade, dass ich auch mit dem Joggingverbot
genau falsch gelegen habe aber Ausgangsbeschränkungen, also jetzt von zweiundzwanzig bis fünf Uhr und Sport alleine bis vierundzwanzig Uhr erlaubt.
So, also ja und das heißt,
ja, also so sieht's aus und über hundert außerdem an den Schulen soll dann zweimal pro Woche testen bei Wechselunterricht.
Durchgeführt werden, also Schulen bleiben halt auf, aber bis
eben da gibt's die neue Grenze von hundertfünfundsechzig, die vorher zweihundert war, aber wenn jetzt die Inzidenz an drei aufeinanderfolgenden Tagen über hundertfünfundsechzig
ist, dann ist nur noch Distanz
zuständig, also dann werden die Schulen im Grunde genommen zugemacht, mit aber Ausnahmen bei Abschlussklassen äh wiederum, die können dann trotzdem in Präsenzunterricht haben und einige Länder.
Interpretieren auch die vierten Grundschulklassen als Abschulklassen im Moment und wollen die halt auch stattfinden lassen bis äh äh egal also offen halten auch wenn,
so. Dann des Weiteren.
Über hundert gilt halt jetzt.
Eine Begrenzung der Kundenzahl äh bei den, bei den Geschäften, mit Ausnahmen von Supermärkten und äh generell äh ja es täglichen Bedarfs und Maskenpflicht und so.
Und äh bis hundertfünfzig.
Ist noch Terminshopping mit Tests und Maske im urigen Einzelhandel möglich.
Muss der übrige Einzelhandel schließen und nur die Supermärkte bleiben.
Äh auf. Und dann äh bei Sport gilt halt jetzt im Freien, individual Sport mit maximal zwei Personen.
Oder eigenem Haushalt und kontaktloser Gruppensport für Kinder von fünf bis vierzehn Jahren ist auch noch möglich, ja.
So, also, ne.
Höchstens fünf Kinder.
Ja, in Gruppen von höchstens fünf Kindern, ja, bis vierzehn Jahre auch noch, äh, genau. Ja,
So, alles weiteren werden bei der Inzidenz über hundert alle Kultur und Freizeiteinrichtungen äh geschlossen,
und äh für körpernahe Dienstleistungen und Friseure und,
Fußpflege und so ist aber immer noch dann äh mit FFP-Maske und bei Friseuren und Fußpflege mit Test, dann äh äh möglich, also auch sich die Haare über hundert schneiden zu lassen
und in der Gastronomie eben, die bleibt geschlossen. Über hundert und.
Abholung und Lieferdienste sind aber möglich. So, das sind so.
Die wesentlichen Regelungen, glaube ich, die die Bundesnotbremse.
Bringt und einige Länder haben.
Schon bisher auch schärfere oder etwas andere.
Regelungen in Berlin ändert sich zum Beispiel, dass Berlin jetzt auf den RKI-Grenzwert.
Umschwenkt auf den offiziellen, weil Berlin hatte bisher eben ja, selber äh seine Inzidenz.
Berechnet und da die eben immer viel höher war als die RKI
Inzidenz, also weil die bisher ehrlicher war, sind sie halt, äh aber jetzt, weil äh na ja, sagen, macht halt, es ja, macht halt.
Also wenn wir jetzt auch Konsequenzen ziehen wollen, dann nehmen wir zumindest erstmal den niedrigeren Leitwert.
Genau, dann nehmen wir jetzt den niedrigeren äh Leitwert und damit ist halt.
Sind diese dusselige vier Tage Ampelregelung jetzt endlich gestorben.
Nichts, dass ich wusste, nee, die vier Tage äh Ampel äh blinkt halt irgendwie immer noch vor sich her und auf Rot äh überwiegend, also zwischen rot und gelb und äh ja.
Also springt von links nach rechts. Alter, oh man, ey, das tut echt so weh, ne? Das ist das ist echt keine Notbremse, sondern das ist irgendwie Bundesnotbremse, Total Lenzcaping. Also es ist einfach.
Ja. Ja.
Da bremst gar nix ein hin und her Gehüpfer und das das der quillt einfach der Kompromiss links und rechts raus und.
Das versteht ja auch kein Mensch.
Also erstmal, ich war natürlich auch erstmal äh ich meine, haben ja viele auch gehört oder so, dass wir halt ähm ja, dass das im Grunde genommen schon,
katastrophales und eigentlich das mehr oder weniger Festschreiben einer hochinzidenz ähm.
Jedenfalls äh für eine ganze Weile und äh nicht eben uns wirklich äh,
mit dem Ziel, ja, näher bringt oder also es bringt uns vielleicht ein bisschen näher, aber nur vorübergehend meiner Meinung nach.
Nämlich dem Ziel, wieder aufmachen zu können und sicher öffnen zu können und,
auch eine Perspektive zu haben, dass halt offen bleibt,
So, das ist äh halt der der Punkt, weil was jetzt viele eben befürchten,
ist halt so eine, ich sage mal, Thermostat-Funktion von dieser Notbremse, dass ihm jetzt ja, die Inzidenz steigt, dann werden Dinge zugemacht, dann fällt sie, dann werden sie wieder aufgemacht
geht dann wieder hoch, steigt und so weiter, dass uns das halt jetzt so blühen könnte. Deshalb.
Schulen und Einzelhandel dann so, wie sagt man im Prinzip, alle zwei oder drei Wochen äh auf oder zumachen, so lange,
bis denn dann.
Genug geimpft wird und es warm genug wird, dass äh die Zahlen eben nicht mehr hochgehen, wenn dann wieder geöffnet wird.
Aber im Moment steht das halt zu befürchten und.
Diese Inzidenzen natürlich von hundert oder hundertfünfundsechzig auch sind halt viel zu hoch. Äh so im Moment, also wir reden da halt ja,
von ähm im Moment tausendfünfhundert Toten jede Woche und das geht zwar leicht zurück, beziehungsweise jetzt ist es wieder leicht angestiegen, aber,
Ja, ich finde halt, tausendfünfhundert Tote sind einfach zu viel.
Zumindest müsste man sich jetzt langsam mal drauf einigen, dass man die nächsten zwanzig Jahre über Terroranschläge überhaupt nicht mehr berichten darf. Wenn jetzt irgendwie tausendfünfhundert Tote pro Woche irgendwie völlig okay ist.
Ja, gut. Es ist immer,
ich meine, da ist dann stellt sich natürlich immer die Frage, das eine ist sagenden willkürlich herbei äh oder absichtlich herbeigeführter Akt ähm.
Jetzt bei,
Covid äh ist es so, dass es eben ja, man sagt, okay, das ist halt auch Lebensrisiko und Krankheiten gibt's und wir tun unser Bestes und äh aber ja, im Grunde genommen, wie wir auch gezeigt,
haben oder wie wenn man sich die Phasen ansieht,
ist das halt schon ziemlich krass. Also sind sind schon viele Leute gestorben, die nicht hätten sterben müssen, dass das ist ganz klar.
Und vor allem, was aus aus dieser Regelung auch wieder heraustrifft wie nichts Gutes ist, einfach die totale Ziellosigkeit. Also das ist einfach.
Einfach kein Ziel, sondern das Ziel ist einfach Augen zu und durch,
hat aber dann einer was gegen die Konsequenzen. Na dann tun wir zumindest so ein bisschen so als würden wir irgendwas tun.
Gutes Ziel, also das Ziel, glaube ich, was dahinter steckt, ist eben äh eine Überlastung,
äh zu verhindern, dass Gesundheitswesens, also es ist irgendwo zum Zusammenbruch kommt, dass es das einzige Ziel.
Es ist aber kein Ziel, ja. Das das ist das ist also in meiner Welt ist das kein Ziel, sondern das ist sozusagen nur so ein Zwischenziel.
Gut, das ist eigentlich ist es, ich sage mal, ist es selbstverständlich, dass man das nicht zulassen will und ist jetzt auch kein besonders anspruchsvolles Ziel, muss ich sagen.
Ja, man will einfach äh es geht nicht mehr darum, sich nicht zu verletzen, sondern es geht nur darum, dass man nicht so viel blutet. Und das.
Oder dass man nicht nicht mehr blutet äh als.
Aber ich blute. Ja, aber das war doch jetzt nur ein halber Liter im in der letzten Stunde.
Genau und äh irgendwann, das hört schon irgendwann, es hört schon irgendwann auf, dass äh ja, also wir geben dir hier jetzt, also wir, ja, genau, wir wir tun da mal ein Pflaster drauf, äh.
Und dann äh ja gucken wir mal. Also irgendwann, es wird auch irgendwann wärmer und da trocknet das Blut dann schneller und so. Ja. Ähm.
Nee, ich meine, ja, immer tatsächlich, hm, tatsächlich ist es so, dass.
Jetzt uns gewisse Dinge entgegenkommen. Wie gesagt, das Wetter, es wird jetzt wärmer erstmal, die Sanität hilft uns und.
Äh B eins eins fünf ist jetzt auch so ziemlich durch. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt irgendwie bei fünfundneunzig Prozent. Das heißt, da kommt jetzt nicht mehr B eins eins fünf nach. So, da sind wir also auch quasi am Anschlag.
Und hm ja und dann wird schreiten halt die Impfungen voran. Das heißt eigentlich äh hat es hat das Virus es schon jetzt zunehmend.
Schwerer so, das heißt, ja, da gibt es Kräfte, die die Arbeiten für uns, aber so.
Ja, die Aktivitäten und Kontakte wiederum, vor allem die Schulen.
Aber auch hm ja Arbeit.
Das sind halt so die die Hauptdinge,
ähm die reichen wahrscheinlich aus im Moment noch, um dann doch den R-Wert erstmal wieder über eins zu bringen, wenn die halt offen äh sind,
sobald halt geöffnet wird und irgendwann wird es nicht mehr der Fall sein, aber meine Befürchtung ist, dass äh wir.
Ja äh jetzt das Bild sehen werden, dass in.
Landkreisen, die jetzt irgendwo drüber sind, wird man jetzt die und die Notbremse greift. Wir haben ja dann Rückgänge sehen. In anderen äh Bereichen,
haben wir halt, wo, wo Schulen offen sind, werden wir Anstiege sehen und,
das Ganze wird sich dann zu so einem wieder zehn Gesamt,
verbinden, dass wir das Gefühl haben werden, das geht nicht richtig rauf und es geht nicht richtig runter so und mancherorts geht's rauf, mancherorts äh geht's runter und.
Ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen im Moment, dass wir noch ein Bam äh sehen könnten, dass es nochmal einen Ticken äh einen einen einen Ausschlag macht. Also es fehlt halt noch im Moment.
Die äh letztlich die Ergebnisse jetzt der nach österlichen Schulöffnungen, das das die kommen erst in den letzten Tagen jetzt rein, wenn man so will, weil es gab ja noch länger Sommerferien in weiten.
Und es ist dann auch jetzt langsamer losgegangen und dann kommen noch die.
Zehn Tage Verzögerung zwischen Infektion und Veröffentlichung äh dazu, sodass,
wir jetzt grade in dieser und in der nächsten Woche ungefähr dann sehen werden, was denn die Schulen und die Schulöffnungen äh dann jetzt genau.
Beiträge leisten und guckt man sich die letzten Tage an. Äh sieht man halt das definitiv die Schulen vielerorts, dass das nach oben schießt. Und die Frage ist, wie viel und äh wie lange.
Das der Fall sein. Aber.
Ich sehe, dass das wieder äh wahrscheinlich eher so ein so ein mühsames Spiel werden wird, ein bisschen rauf, ein bisschen runter und äh.
Ja, irgendwann äh dann hoffentlich dann, wenn sich verstetigender Trend, aber wann der zu erwarten ist, da.
Denke ich, äh kann man dann im Zusammenhang mit den Impfungen vielleicht mal drauf kommen, oder? Wie siehst du das?
Genau das wollte ich jetzt auch gerade vorschlagen, also blicken wir mal auf den Teil, der einen vielleicht so ein bisschen Hoffnung machen kann und das ist natürlich der Verlauf der Impfungen in Deutschland.
Und das sieht so aus. Also Stand heute sind zweiundzwanzig Komma zwei Prozent der Bevölkerung, also ein Fünftel, bisschen mehr. Äh erst geimpft.
Und äh voll geimpft sind sieben Prozent,
Da jetzt auch so die Distanz von der Erstimpfung zur Zweitimpfung, also bei Biotech ist es ja, also bei den MRN Arsch äh Impfstoffen ist es jetzt auf sechs Wochen erweitert worden bei den Vektor-Impfstoffen, also bei Asra,
zwölf Wochen, weil man einfach gesehen hat, okay, der Effekt, der Erstimpfung ist relativ stark,
Wir können das nach hinten rauszögern und das führt dann eben auch zu mehr Erstimpfung. Und das sieht man im Prinzip auch den Zahlen ganz gut an. Ja, während die Erstimpfung also steil.
Relativ steil ansteigen. Derzeit ähm ist das eben bei den Zweitimpfungen noch nicht so, weil die ja im Prinzip jetzt äh verschobene Termine haben und eben nur das Impfgeschehen von vor,
drei, vier, fünf, sechs, sieben bis zu zwölf Wochen jetzt äh abbilden.
Das sind also ungefähr vierundzwanzig Millionen Dosen, die da jetzt bisher äh verschossen worden. Und.
Ich blicke schon seit längerem auf dieses Impf-Dashboard,
und habe mich immer so gefragt, was ich eigentlich aus diesen Zahlen machen soll. Das Problem ist dieses hat so ein bisschen so diesen Blick auf die letzte Woche
und man merkt halt auch, wie schon bei den Meldungen der Infektion, auch bei den,
Zahlen der Impfungen, dass die so der christlichen Logistik äh Funktion folgen, sprich die schwanken extremen Wochenrhythmus. Also es ist eigentlich immer so, dass der Mittwoch,
der stärkste Tag ist, manchmal ist es auch der Donnerstag, auch der Freitag kann gut mithalten, aber am Wochenende ist immer relativ wenig los und am Montag läuft's irgendwie langsam an.
Womit das im Einzelnen zusammenhängt, äh habe ich irgendwann aufgehört, mich zu fragen, es ist halt so. Und äh das impft der Sport,
bietet zwar so eine hm ja so eine Aufstellung der täglichen Impfzahlen, aber das fluktuiert halt so extrem, sodass ich mir gedacht habe so, hm, vielleicht sollte man sich das auch mal so im Wochenmittel anschauen.
Und da die Daten ja dort auch zum Download angeboten werden, dankenswerterweise von Anfang an, habe ich mir einfach mal die Daten geschnappt und mal selber äh so ein bisschen,
Mia ähm das zusammengerechnet und eine kleine Grafik gemacht. Die findet ihr auch in den Shownotes. Ich habe sie auch schon mal äh vertwittert.
Und da sieht man dann eben, dass sich diese Zahlen doch sehr.
Beruhigen, also was vorher so 'ne hektische Ausschlagekurve ist, zeichnet dann eben das Impfgeschehen so mit 'nem gewissen Delay nach und man sieht so in etwa, was eigentlich wirklich ähm,
passiert es bisher. Und da kann man dann irgendwie draus,
ablesen, dass es tatsächlich bisher ungefähr so äh drei Impfphasen gegeben hat.
Also es gab so die Anfangsphase, wo.
Relativ viel Impfstoff ähm für die Impfkapazitäten, die zu dem Zeitpunkt
bestanden, also die Impfzentren, die schnell aufgemacht haben, äh zur Verfügung stand und der dann eben ratzefatze verimpft wurde.
Ähm und das stagnierte aber dann eben eine Weile, ne, weil dann kam halt nicht so viel nach. Man hat
quasi von der Vorproduktion profitiert, die aber dann nicht nennenswert,
gesteigert werden konnte, dann kam so die Zweitimpfung nach und dauerte dann bis zum Februar bis Zahlen erstmalig so ein bisschen anzogen. Und ähm im.
Ende Februar, Anfang März,
das dann so langsam hoch, dass man so auf Zahlen von ungefähr zweihunderttausend kam, aber wenn man sich dann die Kurve anschaut, gab's dann halt zwei Knicke.
Und die beiden Knigge kann ich gleich vorwegnehmen. Das ist natürlich diese Astra Senica Konfusion, die aufkam, weil.
Ja, erstmal Impfstoff war und dann wurde es wieder zugelassen und dann war wieder Impfstoff und ähm so ging's halt äh die ganze Zeit hin und her.
Mitte März jetzt.
Genau, Mitte, Mitte März, ne, Mitte, Ende März und ähm jetzt im
April wiederum schossen dann auf einmal die Impfzahlen nach oben
weil eben jetzt die Lieferung von Biotech von der Produktionsstätte in Marburg aufschlugen
und die Verfügbarkeit entsprechend höher war und was natürlich auch noch mit dazu kommt, ist, dass eben diese Haus
Arzt-Impfung extrem zugenommen haben. Also es gab sowohl auf einmal mehr Impfstoff als auch mehr Kapazität, diese zu verimpfen und dann sind halt die Impfzahlen relativ schnell so aus dem Zweihunderttausender in den vierhunderttausender Bereich
gekommen.
Wobei, wie hoch ist jetzt die, sagen wir Beitrag, der Ärzte, also was ich gesehen hatte, jetzt vor ein paar Tagen, noch äh lief das äh schon an
war aber unter der, also jetzt bei den Gesamtimpfungen zumindest noch nicht äh natürlich klar
äh wenn die Impfzentren impfen seit Monaten äh und so, aber was ist das, so zahlen, wie das so sagen, wie sich das verteilt im Moment zwischen Impfzentren und niedergelassenen Ärzten? Das ändert sich natürlich super äh schnell, aber ja.
Also es geht aus den, aus diesen Daten, die ich jetzt
bisher benutzt habe, so direkt nicht vor. Das steht jetzt nicht wo das verimpft wurde. Ähm was ich mir allerdings in der nächsten Woche nochmal genauer anschauen möchte, das brauche ich eh für eine bessere Vorhersage. Sind die detaillierten Zahlen vom Bundesgesundheits
die Prognosen, was denn so geliefert wird? Die haben mich nämlich am Anfang ein bisschen verwirrt, bis ich dann festgestellt habe, dass sie die Lieferung der Impfzentren und die Lieferung für die Hausärzte separat aufführen, völlig äh
hat aber den Vorteil, dass man eben daraus in etwa den Anteil festmachen kann. So aus dem Bauch heraus
ohne das jetzt überprüft zu haben, würde ich sagen, es macht ungefähr so die Hälfte aus.
Ich gucke grade hier mal, weil ich habe nämlich vor ein paar Tagen mal.
RKI dieses Excel zum digitalen Impfquoten-Monitoring und da ist das nämlich äh auch noch aufgeschlüsselt, auch nach Impfstoffen und.
Auch nach Impfungen der niedergelassenen Ärzteschaft äh ja und.
Ist es so, dass jetzt die niedergelassene Ärzteschaft, also von irgendwelche Kalenderwoche ist, dass jetzt hier bis, also bis,
zwanzigsten vierten jetzt genau bis einschließlich zwanzigsten vierten, ist also jetzt schon noch ein.
Ein paar Tage her sieht's wohl so aus, dass die niedergelassenen Ärzte.
Hundertzweiundneunzigtausend Erst.
Impfungen gemacht haben am Vortag und und tausendsiebenhundert Zweitimpfungen.
Während die Impfzentren äh ja.
Zweihundertvierundachtzig, oh ja. Ja, doch, das ist also hm, ja. Also, die, wenn ich mir das so angucke, sind, äh, sind eher bald bei halbe, halbe.
Genau, also ich, wie gesagt, mit so Tagesvergleichen kommt man nirgendswo hin. Also das ist einfach genauso trügerisch wie bei den Infuktionszahlen. Man muss sich wirklich alles im Wochenmittel äh anschauen,
ich hab's mir, wie gesagt, also die ich habe jetzt grade erstmal damit angefangen und will jetzt eben vor allem für eine bessere Prognose, wie sich das jetzt entwickelt, die
liefert zu sagen mir nochmal genau anschauen in dem Zusammenhang vielleicht auch nochmal den Anteil rausrechnen auch wenn's mir ehrlich gesagt am Ende des Tages völlig egal ist
welchen Anteil hat äh das Hauptproblem ist halt einfach nach wie vor die Lieferung von Impfstoffen. Wir haben genug Kapazität
Also die Ärzte leiden eher da drunter, dass sie sehr unzuverlässige Zusagen bekommen. Da geht's also wirklich, was ich so höre.
Da geht's hin und her, ja, also heute wird irgendwie gesagt, äh jetzt, jetzt kommt der Impfstoff und dann dann kommt morgen nix und dann wird das wieder äh dann dann kriegt man auch irgendwie eine Absage und dann steht am nächsten Tag jemand mit einem Paket vor der Tür. So ging das äh die ganze Zeit
Dazu kommt jetzt auch noch, äh da komme ich gleich nochmal drauf zu, die ganze Situation um Astra Zinnecke. Aber vielleicht jetzt erstmal nur die reinen Zahlen, was ich jetzt aus diesen Impfstatistik
rausgelesen habe. Also wir sind derzeit bei einem Schnitt von vierhundertfünfzigtausend. Das hielt sich jetzt die ganze letzte Woche.
Und ist jetzt in den letzten zwei Tagen wieder eingeknickt. Ja, ich meine, wenn du jetzt grade so aufgehst
dann siehst du so, oh ja hier, Donnerstag sechshunderttausend Impfungen, alles geil, Mittwoch sogar fast siebenhunderttausend Impfungen
Mhm. Nur zeigt es dir halt eben nicht den Mittwoch und den Donnerstag der Woche davor an. Und deswegen gehen halt die Zahlen tatsächlich ein bisschen nach,
und äh was das aber schon anzeigt, ist, dass eben derzeit, Stand heute fünfundneunzig Komma drei Prozent der gelieferten Impfdosen auch tatsächlich verimpft worden ist. Das heißt, wir haben eine höhere Effizienz im Impfen.
Es wird einfach verimpft, was sozusagen die Lager hergeben
Ne, man muss ja bedenken, es wird immer ein gewisser Teil auch noch für Zweitimpfungen grade zurückgehalten und so eine Quote von fünfundneunzig Komma drei Prozent, wie sie sich heute darstellt, hatten wir bisher äh
noch nie, also noch nie ist so anteilig so viel von dem Gelieferten auch tatsächlich verimpft worden,
Und jetzt hängt es einfach davon ab, dass diese Lieferung auch entsprechend äh gesteigert werden.
Wohlgemerkt, ich beziehe mich jetzt hier nur auf erst.
Impfungen, ne? Das ist äh der wichtige äh äh Faktor. Die sechshunderttausend, die ich jetzt grade eben genannt hatte, das sind halt Impfdosen, die halt erstmal so überhaupt nichts äh aussagen, weil eben dieses spezifische Verhältnis zwischen erst und Zweitimpfung
wichtig ist und äh.
Man kann halt einfach sagen, in dem Moment, wo wir irgendwie bei fünfzig Prozent der äh Erstimpfung sind, drei Wochen äh drei Monate später,
Sind dann eben auch alle zweigeimpft, aber ich denke, für uns ist diese Erstimpfung das, was einfach grade wirklich wichtig ist,
Jetzt sind für die nächsten Wochen oder sagen wir mal für die nächsten zwei Monate, ähm,
in etwa, das habe ich aber jetzt noch nicht im Detail nach den offiziellen Meldungen nachgerechnet. Fünf Millionen Dosen pro Woche zugesagt worden.
Und so wie ich das bisher aus den Zahlen rauslesen kann, also man kann ja quasi aus den Erstimpfungen der letzten vier bis sechs Wochen, wenn man den,
Anteil an den Impfstoffen dann auch berücksichtigt, was ich eben derzeit noch nicht tue, in etwa eine Vorhersage machen, wie viel Zweitimpfung es geben
müsste. Und das dann eben bei diesen Impfstoffen rausrechnen und dann bleiben eben die Erstimpfung über. Also ich mache jetzt nur mal so eine ganz
lockere Annahme, dass wir in den nächsten Wochen auf ungefähr sechshundert, vielleicht sechshundertdreißigtausend Erstimpfungen.
Pro Tag kommen könnten im Schnitt. Wenn's gut läuft. Und das ist dann schon ganz ordentlich
ne? Weil das würde eben wirklich bedeuten
Sollte sich das so konsolidieren und nicht wieder irgendwelche Einbußen äh passieren, indem irgendwas nicht geliefert wird, dass wir so bis Ende Juni diese fünfzig Prozent Marke auch locker überschreiten. Also das
würde durchaus bedeuten, dass wir dann schon so im besten Fall auf sechzig bis siebzig Prozent äh erst äh Geimpfte kommen können.
Das ist aber jetzt noch.
Das ist jetzt keine Zahl, für die ich mich äh in der nächsten Woche an an den Baum nageln lasse, ja. Das das muss ich schon noch mal etwas genauer nachrechnen. Das ist jetzt eine relativ frische Überlegung. Ich wollte einfach nur mal so ein Gefühl dafür bekommen,
passiert jetzt eigentlich gerade? Geht passiert jetzt irgendwie da äh nennenswert irgendwas?
Zeichnet sich ab, dass es besser wird oder nicht. Und ich sage,
Ja, es zeichnet sich ab, ich rechne in den nächsten ein bis zwei Wochen damit, dass wir in so eine vierte Impfphase gehen, wo wir dann eben
so auf sechshunderttausend pro Tag kommen könnten. Und das ist dann schon ganz gut. Das ist dann schon etwas so eine Perspektive, wo man sagen kann, im Sommer erreichen wir dann auch,
Zahlen in Deutschland, die Israel,
als sie sie erreicht haben, Israel dazu geführt haben, dass das ganze Infektionsgeschehen und vor allem auch das Sterbegeschehen doch nachhaltig davon,
beeinflusst wurde. Aber noch nicht alles vorbei, aber dann gingen die Zahlen runter, umso älter die Leute waren, umso mehr,
und einen ähnlichen Effekt würde ich mir hier halt auch davon versprechen.
Irgendwann im letzten halben Jahr auch nur ein einziges Mal dann äh sähe, dass da äh viel besser aus und wir hätten vor allem nicht das Problem,
dass wir jetzt hier noch dieses Risiko fahren mit den ganzen Geimpften noch uns irgendwie äh impfresistente äh Virenvarianten einzutreten, ne.
Ja, das Lustige ist, dass ich halt jetzt auch in der Woche, ohne dass wir uns abgesprochen hatten, erstmal ich genau äh mir diese Frage äh etwas genauer angeschaut habe, nämlich.
Wie ist es denn jetzt in Israel gelaufen?
Warte mal ganz kurz, bevor wir auf Israel kommen, äh lass mich kurz noch den Punkt zu Ende äh bringen, weil ich habe mir dann auch nochmal angeschaut,
welche Impfstoffe spielen jetzt eigentlich gerade die größte Rolle.
Weil das äh gibt's sozusagen auch noch und habe mir mal so einen Plot gemacht, der eben äh einfach die verimpften Dosen nach Hersteller äh aufschlüsselt. So, einfach mal ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen.
Und da kann man eben sehr gut sehen, äh was hier die eigentlichen Treiber sind, ne, also wir haben vom Dezember bis zum April soll eine kontinuierliches Anwachsen sowohl bei.
Ähm auf hohem Niveau, als auch bei moderner, aufm sehr viel niedrigeren Niveau
Ja? Und während moderner, seitdem mehr oder weniger konstant weiter äh dümpelt, so bei fünfundzwanzigtausend äh Impfdosen pro Tag.
Ging Biotech.
Anfang April halt durch die äh durch die Decke. Das heißt, da kam dann.
Von zweihunderttausend auf bis zu vierhunderttausend
Impfdosen pro Tag, die halt äh hier ins Geschehen mit eingegriffen haben, während halt Asrasinika wenig überraschend im
totale Schlangenlinie gemacht hat. Und genau diese Schlangenlinie sieht man eben dann letzten Endes auch im Impfgeschehen. Also wir waren schon auf einem sehr guten Weg von äh Anfang
Februar bis äh Anfang März ging also die Lieferung da bis hunderttausend hoch, dann ist es wieder eingebrochen, dann ging's wieder hoch, ist wieder eingebrochen,
Also sie ist nicht die Lieferung, sondern was
konkret verimpft wurde, ne? Durch diesen Impfstoff ging's dann halt nicht äh weiter. Und es hat sich nur so ansatzweise erholt. Jetzt geht's langsam wieder hoch, weil ich das Gefühl habe, jetzt werden gerade so die restlichen Lager leer gemacht.
Dazu kommt ja jetzt auch noch so diese Meldung, die ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig verstanden habe, dass jetzt auf einmal die Impfprioritäten für
aufgehoben werden in manchen Bundesländern. Gehen nicht alle mit, Berlin macht's, Brandenburg macht's nicht
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern macht's, ähm wo ich mich auch frage, was das jetzt eigentlich wieder soll. Ich habe da mal bei Hausärzten nachgefragt und die so, ja, äh welches Asra Senior eigentlich?
Kriegen das gar nicht mehr, weil dieses Initialprogramm, wo die Asrainiker an die Hausärzte ging, das ist jetzt wieder abgesagt worden und man soll sich das jetzt irgendwie wieder bei der Apotheke
äh besorgen und die Apotheken so, welches Astranica. Also da ist noch eine totale Lieferchaos und keiner weiß eigentlich, wo das jetzt äh herkommen soll. Deswegen kann man sich eigentlich komplett auf Biotech konzentrieren. In der nächsten Zeit, glaube ich, für irgendwelche Voraussagen.
So, nächste Woche mehr dazu und jetzt gucken wir doch mal, was äh ist eigentlich in Israel los.
Ja. Also in Israel äh muss man erstmal sagen, ist die äh ältere Bevölkerung.
Extrem stark äh äh durchgeimpft. Also äh und der Rest,
eigentlich auch, wir reden da so von Impfquoten äh jenseits von äh neunzig Prozent bis hin zu achtundneunzig Prozent
Erstimpfungen und äh da kann man sagen, die sind schon
verdammt weit und da ist jetzt, ich glaube deutlich mehr als die Hälfte der der Bevölkerung äh geimpft äh so in,
in Israel und selbst,
zwanzig bis neunundzwanzig jährigen ähm sind wir schon bei siebzig Prozent,
Erstimpfungen äh äh so und ähm ja ähm.
Und sogar die Kinder, also Israel hat jetzt schon sogar zwanzig Prozent von den Zehn- bis Neunzehnjährigen äh äh durchgeimpft. Und.
Insgesamt sind's aber nur siebenundfünfzig Komma acht Prozent, ne, muss man sagen. Und zwei, also durchgeimpft und knapp vierundfünfzig Prozent.
Aber das geht dann zum großen Teil auch auf die relativ junge Bevölkerung äh zurück.
Bis sieht halt so aus, dass ähm man äh im Grunde genommen, wenn man jetzt die Fünfzig-Prozent,
überschreitet äh so an Impfquote, dass man dann äh wohl mit dem Lockern äh beginnen,
kann, ohne dass einem das jetzt dann äh ja um die Ohren äh fliegt und Israel.
Hatte eben ähm.
Ja äh mit also bei Israel war der der Höhepunkt.
Äh der der Auslastung äh auch der ähm.
Der Patienten auf den Intensivstationen war Ende Januar. Da hatten die halt so tausendeinhundertneunundachtzig Intensivpatienten.
Und äh ja sind eben jetzt auf hunderteinundsechzig runter innerhalb von drei Monaten, ja? Das heißt, so vom Gipfel,
in Israel bis jetzt zu Entspannung. Ich meine, das ist jetzt, es ist.
Da hat sich das jetzt schon vor ein paar Wochen begonnen zu entspannen, aber man sieht halt, ich meine hundertneunundsechzig auf Intensivstationen und
Ja, es findet eben trotzdem auch noch Infektion statt, aber der R-Wert liegt so konstant äh so etwa bei null Komma acht, das heißt, da geht's halt
eben ganz gut runter und tatsächlich der zweiundzwanzigste vierte.
Jetzt äh war der Tag, wo zum ersten Mal in Israel niemand gestorben ist an Covid, also wo es.
Null Tote gab,
und ja, das äh fand ich schon mal gut, das wäre ich ich glaube, das wäre so bei uns auch ein Meilenstein. Gut, wir sind natürlich größer und so, das heißt, das wird wahrscheinlich wird dann nochmal länger äh äh dauern, aber.
Ähm ja, wir aber wir hatten eben durchaus auch im Sommer äh den den
den Zustand und ich glaube, äh wenn wir da angekommen sind, so wieder bei einem Tag ohne Tote, äh dann ähm ja
dann tanze ich auch äh so dann äh weil
Ich hatte halt versprochen, wenn die Zahlen dabei sind, die Zahlen halt jetzt runtergehen ohne Maßnahmen, dann würde ich einen Freudentanz aufführen und äh deshalb äh tanzen werde ich jetzt erst
ja, wenn.
Wir da sind, wo Israel äh jetzt ist und dann habe ich mich natürlich gefragt, okay, bei denen momentan, also von unserer Inzidenz aus und von den Impfquoten aus und so,
ähm wie lange brauchen wir denn jetzt, also was ist denn jetzt so ein auf der Basis von Israel, ein realistisches Szenario ähm,
ja auf auf uns halt angepasst und da habe ich mir dann erstmal äh nochmal eine Inzidenz
Vergleich gemacht und wenn man dann einfach auf äh guckt, stellt man fest, wo, also Israel hat ja irgendwie Inzidenzen so fast von tausend äh jetzt noch
im äh Januar oder über die Jahreswende und bei uns, wir sind ja eher so auf ähm etwas über zweihundert, so zweihundertvierzig, glaube ich,
gekommen,
so das heißt Israel hatte ja scheinbar 'nen viel höheren 'ne viel höhere Inzidenz.
So, aber äh dann habe ich mir unsere schöne positiven äh Rate äh mal angeschaut und,
verglichen und da sieht man dann, dass wir im Januar eine höhere, positiven Quote hatte als.
Israel je geschafft hat. Klar, natürlich testen die auch, aber das ist erstmal also die positiven Rate ist dann erstmal eine Inzidenz dafür,
äh eine höhere bei uns,
als in Israel, dass also wir die Inzidenzen nicht so ohne Weiteres vergleichen können, sondern dass wir im Grunde genommen also wenn Deutschland so viel getestet hätte, wie Israel wären
unsere äh Werte deutlich höher gewesen und das zweite Ding, was man halt zum Normieren gerne benutzt, ist,
so die Zahl der Todesfälle.
Pro Bevölkerung und da sind wir sogar sagen dreißig Prozent in der Spitze.
Über Israel auch gelegen, also mit anderen Worten bei uns sind auch mehr,
Leute gestorben als äh in Israel und zwar na sowohl auf dem Höhepunkt als auch wenn man sich das jetzt kumuliert äh anschaut.
War es so, dass äh ja, mittlerweile eben äh.
Israel ist es jetzt zum zum Halt gekommen und wir haben ungefähr äh bislang pro Bevölkerung äh fünfundzwanzig Prozent mehr Covid äh Tote als äh,
Israel, aber Israel hat, glaube ich, auch einen Durchschnittsalter in der Bevölkerung von dreißig Jahren. Und äh wir liegen, glaube ich,
über fünfzig äh im Moment. Das heißt, Israel hat auch eine im Durchschnitt zwanzig Jahre jüngere Bevölkerung, was man eigentlich auch wieder irgendwie hier mit.
Mit äh einbeziehen und rausrechnen müsste, aber lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, äh so ähm.
Man kann die Inzidenzen nicht direkt vergleichen äh und wahrscheinlich
äh kann man äh muss schon sagen, dass möglicherweise sogar wir stärker betroffen waren äh von äh Covid Infektionen
als äh das bei Israel der Fall war, obwohl die die reinen Zahlen eben völlig anders äh aussehen.
Und ja, wenn man dann so einen Blick dann auf den Vergleich, ja, wie lief's denn,
bei uns mit dem Impfen und wie lief's denn in Israel mit dem Impfen, denn.
Stellt man erstmal fest, je nachdem welche Daten man nimmt, oh wow, wir haben ja Israel beim Impfen überholt. So, aber leider nur in absoluten Zahlen.
Aber ich fand's halt auch lustig, fragte mich nur, äh wann denn die Politik äh mit dieser Erfolgsmeldung äh um die Ecke kommt, dass wir jetzt irgendwie
mehr impfen als Israel und das ist auch tatsächlich wahr. Es ist so und also sowohl ähm in also in absoluten äh äh Zahlen jedenfalls, in, in, in, in Impfdosen
Aber natürlich, wenn man das auf die Bevölkerung umrechnet, äh sieht's natürlich komplett,
anders aus da ist es so, ja, dass in Israel jetzt einfach äh fünfmal so viel Leute äh durchgeimpft sind und.
Und dann gibt's im, wenn man sich sehr schön anschauen, wenn man sich dann jetzt die Impfdosen pro hundert äh.
Also auf die Bevölkerung bezogen anschaut in Israel und in Deutschland, wie das zeitlich gelaufen ist, dann sind wir mittlerweile
auch äh sozusagen bei den täglichen Impfdosen pro hundert Leute sind wir.
Auch jetzt über Israel, weil natürlich in Israel das jetzt runtergegangen ist, aber wenn man sich äh Januar,
den Februar und auch noch ein Teil des vom März anguckt, dann sieht man halt, dass Israel ein.
Einen massives Impftempo hingelegt, hat so sechs bis acht Mal so hoch.
So wie wir zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Was jetzt auch wenig überraschend ist. Ich meine, wenn wir das Modellland gewesen wären und wir hätten äh äh vergleichbar hohe Lieferungen erhalten, dann äh wäre das wahrscheinlich hier auch genauso gelaufen, ne.
Das soll jetzt auch kein Vorwurf sein, aber was man halt erwarten kann dann jetzt mit sagen mit Verzögerung dann irgendwann, also wenn wir sagen, in der selben Zeit,
dasselbe erreichen,
wollen, so äh dann äh kann man da sehen, ja, welches Impftempo man äh dort äh vorlegen muss und wie wir es eigentlich noch
steigern müssten und ich sehe, dass wir äh sozusagen die täglichen Impfungen nochmal um den Faktor, ja.
Drei, vier, fünf ungefähr, so was in der Größenordnung, je nachdem nochmal äh äh so viel verimpfen müssten, um.
Als im Vergleich zu was?
Im Vergleich zu dem jetzt, äh was wir jetzt äh sozusagen aktuell pro Tag verimpfen, um.
Was ähnliches hinzuliegen wie in Israel, nämlich innerhalb von ja im Prinzip drei Monaten.
Zwei oder drei Monaten dahin zu kommen, ähm so, wo äh Israel in zwei oder drei Monaten hingekommen ist und da sieht es im Moment so aus für mich.
Dass wir einfach langsamer sind als Israel äh trotz jetzt drei Monate später, also.
Im Vergleich zu sagen, wo Israel vor drei Monaten war und äh dass wir äh ja, länger brauchen werden, einfach. Ja, beim, also um.
An die Impfquoten äh ranzukommen oder die durch Impfung der Bevölkerung, die Israel dann in,
drei Monaten geschafft haben, bedenke ich, werden mir eher vier, fünf, sechs Monate äh äh brauchen noch von von jetzt.
Möglicherweise. Äh abhängig davon.
Wie schnell jetzt äh nochmal nachgelegt wird. Aber in dem Tempo äh wie jetzt verimpft wird, ist klar äh so.
Wird es nichts bis.
Gut, also ich meine, wenn wir von Tempo des Impfen reden, reden wir immer von Lieferungen
Ne, also ich habe relativ wenig Zweifel, dass wir in Deutschland das Impftempo relativ schnell hochdrehen können. Wenn du allen Arztpraxen, die bereit sind, mitzuimpfen, auch die entsprechenden Mengen bereitstellst und vor allem auch,
eine Liefersicherheit garantieren kannst, weil die haben natürlich auch teilweise das Problem, dass die gar nicht wissen, wie viel Termine sie jetzt eigentlich ausmachen.
Ja, also mal abgesehen davon, dass insbesondere Bayern natürlich, also es finden die die mangelhafte Verfügbarkeit von Asra Senicar.
Ist insofern ein Problem, als dass es für einen Hausarzt eine viel höheren Aufwand bedeutet.
Impfstoff zu verimpfen als Lagerproblematik
aber du hast vor allem auch diese Aufbereitungsproblematik, weil jede Viole muss dann irgendwie aufwendig hin und her geshakert werden und so weiter, ganz, ganz, ganz vorsichtig und zerbrechlich ist das Zeug. Während halt Asrasinika ist halt Spritze rein, aufziehen, zack, verimpfen, fertig.
Ne? Und ähm das sind einfach glaube ich so die Haupt äh Spaßbremsen bei dieser ganzen Geschichte.
Plus plus mein Eindruck
äh aber auch, was ich äh gehört habe, dass halt einfach die Aufklärungsgespräche natürlich vor allem im Zusammenhang mit Astra Sindika immer so eine Impfung äh selbst ist
wahrscheinlich zwei Minuten äh gemacht oder drei Minuten gemacht mit mit irgendwie eintragen in den
Impfpass, aber das Aufklärungsgespräch selber, das kann dann schon mal zehn, zwanzig, dreißig, vierzig Minuten
in Anspruch äh nehmen und so und die müssen dann halt auch, ja, wie Fragebogen äh durchgehen und dann noch aufklären. Ähm also
Ja, das ist das, das ist dann eher, aber ich ich.
Vor Längerem schon mal durchgerechnet und äh sage ich mal, wenn genug Impfstoff da wäre, könnten wir,
wenn man äh es jetzt wirklich wollte, könnten wir in zwei Wochen das ganze Land äh durchimpfen.
Vier Wochen überhaupt kein Problem, ja? Mit Hilfe nur der Ärzte, also ohne Impfzentren. Und mit Impfzentren, wie gesagt, äh also es ist alles tatsächlich, wie du sagst, nur eine Frage der.
Impfstoffverfügbarkeit und da habe ich eben auch noch Hoffnung, äh dass dann jetzt die Sachen nachkommen
und jetzt diese Steigerung Anfang April hatte ich das Gefühl, dass das auch damit zusammenhängt. Das war ja das Ende des ersten Quartals. Das hätte ich dann schon
im Januar prognostiziert es wahrscheinlich äh weil eben in den Verträgen sagen wir mal Quartalslieferungen oder so oder
zunächst vereinbart waren, dass dann wahrscheinlich Ende März äh sie dann äh so viel liefern können oder ab Ende März das losgeht, aber vielleicht haben sie auch einfach nur Zeit gleich jetzt die Produktion.
Hochgefahren, aber mein Eindruck war.
Dass ja vertragliche Quartalsgrenzen auch nochmal eine Rolle gespielt haben für diesen für diesen hohen An.
Sprung. So, ja, also mit anderen Worten, um das jetzt mal zusammenzufassen, äh.
Ich sehe noch nicht, dass wir im Momentanen,
momentanen Tempo allzu schnell äh das Israelszenario erreichen. Jedenfalls nicht in den nächsten zwei Monaten.
Ja, das halte ich für.
Unwahrscheinlich und wie lange es dann noch dauert äh wissen wir nicht und das Israelszenario ist halt das, dass aufgrund,
hinreichend hohen Impfquote, mehr Öffnungen stattfinden und die Zahlen trotzdem nicht nach oben.
Also da müssen wir uns nächste Woche nochmal drüber unterhalten. Also meine Schätzung ist eher, geht eher in diese Richtung, dass wir bis Ende Juni, das sind jetzt zehn Wochen, äh schon eine Chance haben auf diese fünfzig Prozent zu kommen.
Ähm vorausgesetzt die äh Lieferungen sind äh stabil. Ne? Erstimpfung, wohlgemerkt, ne.
Wer? Nein.
Ich rede jetzt noch nicht von dem, also ich habe da jetzt nicht einbezogen äh äh sagen, wohin ist äh also wie weit die jetzt noch gesteigert werden können. Ich bin da auch.
Hoffnungsvoll, du hattest gesagt, was erwartest du, also was äh eine eine Steigerung äh lang, wann, auf was?
Also ich halte auf jeden Fall fünfzig Prozent für absolut erreichbar in den nächsten zehn Wochen, wenn wir wirklich diese fünf Millionen haben. Aber ich muss, wie gesagt, deswegen.
Haltung. Ich muss mir nochmal diese genauen Liefer zu sagen. Die haben sich nämlich jetzt auch gerade nochmal geändert,
Muss ich mir nochmal genau rausschauen und ich muss es vor allem dann in Relation setzen
zu welche Impfstoffe sind jetzt eigentlich am Start und wann müssen die Zweitimpfungen stattfinden? Dadurch kann ich dann erst den Anteil der Zweitimpfung machen, um dann rauszufinden, wie bei den Verfügbarkeiten von Impfstoff
Erstimpfung dann möglich,
wären, so oder so, werden wir eine Steigerung sehen und ich denke, nächste Woche, spätestens in zwei Wochen, sind wir so bei sechshunderttausend, aber das werde ich alles noch mal versuchen, in Ruhe nachzurechnen und vielleicht liege ich ja dann sogar richtig, mal gucken.
Ja, gut. Äh sind ja jetzt das Herz aber auch kein Widerspruch. Wenn du sagst, irgendwie zehn Wochen und ich sage, nicht in den nächsten ein bis zwei Monaten
dann ja.
Kann es noch passen.
Passt das ja. Äh so.
Vielleicht.
Ja, okay, vielleicht noch mit mit einem Punkt äh der Anlass, warum ich das überhaupt gemacht hatte.
War halt der, dass mich eben die doch relativ hohen Sterbezahlen einfach beunruhigt haben, äh in den,
hohen Altersgruppen und eben auch äh also ausgelöst hatte das eine Frage, hm müsste jetzt irgendwie nicht die Gruppe neunzig Plus?
Jetzt auch ähm eigentlich komplett durchgeimpft haben und wieso hat die Altersgruppe neunzig Plus so eine extrem.
Hohe äh Inzidenz äh gerade so, also jetzt sagen wir, das war die eine Sache und dann eben äh geguckt, okay.
Wie viele Leute äh sterben denn eben?
Aktuell einfach noch und da sind ja hauptsächlich die älteren Altersgruppen, wo man eigentlich davon ausgehen müsste, gut müssten, nämlich jetzt eigentlich auch bei achtzig, neunzig Prozent oder so liegen und wieso sterben da trotzdem noch äh so viele Leute?
Und ähm.
Und dann äh ja äh habe ich mich, das da kann sich jeder dann auch nochmal auf Twitter anschauen, habe ich mich halt mal so ein bisschen dem Thema im Versager äh angenommen auch und.
Da gibt's sehr wenig jetzt Untersuchungen drüber nach Altersgruppen. Die Zahlen die wir haben.
Sagen, die sind alt gemittelt über, sagen wir mal, alle Altersgruppen.
Und jetzt aber für, ich sage mal, achtzig Plus oder sogar für neunzig Plus gibt's gar nichts. So.
Also bei der Frage wie wie viel Prozent, wie wie wirksam ist eigentlich die Impfung, in welchem Alter? Und.
Da gibt es halt schon den Zusammenhang und der ist auch klar, den gibt's bei allen Impfstoffen, je älter die Leute sind,
umso größer der Anteil einfach der Impfversager.
Das heißt, äh dass äh wir vielleicht, keine Ahnung, neunundneunzig Prozent oder achtundneunzig Prozent Schutz vor irgendwas haben, aber bei älteren Leuten.
Ist äh halt das eben dann nicht so gut. Da ist das Risiko äh größer. Also wir sagen ähm.
Ältere Menschen äh haben ein erhöhtes Risiko, auch wenn sie geimpft sind, äh sich sich anzustecken.
Und auch durchaus schwere Verläufe zu haben und auch zu sterben, auch wenn es halt ganz, ganz wenige äh äh dann nur sind und das wollte ich aber eben mal.
Zahlenmäßig eben rausfinden, weshalb ich halt auch diesen, diesen Blick nach Israel getan habe, um eben aber auch einfach zu gucken.
Was ist denn bei uns mit den alten Leuten? Wann sind die denn sicher? Und das Problem scheint zu sein, dass die halt eben erst sicher sind, wenn die Inzidenzen auch wirklich,
runter äh äh sind, also dass wir eine Kombination brauchen halt aus Impfung und dann,
niedrigen Inzidenzen und deswegen äh ja.
Ist halt sowohl schnelles Impfen, aber eigentlich auch die Inzidenzen runterkriegen nach wie vor äh wichtig. Und meine Befürchtung ist, dass da halt schon äh.
Gerade noch, weil wir eben diese hoch äh Inzidenzpolitik fahren.
Ähm Mindestinzidenzpolitik, wie auch immer.
So dass das dann eben leider noch vor allem viele ältere Leute sterben werden und dass sich dann eben alle Fragen werden, Moment mal.
Ja, wieso? Die sind doch alle geimpft, wo kommt denn das jetzt her?
Und das war so ein bisschen noch der der Hintergrund und nichts genaue Zahlen äh weiß man äh nicht,
Prinzip, ich habe da ein paar Zahlen auch aus den USA äh bekommen darüber, äh wie viele denn jetzt, die geimpft waren, eigentlich sich infiziert haben und wie viele von den Geimpften jetzt dann doch vielleicht,
Verläufe haben oder vielleicht wie viele Geimpfte äh da gestorben sind und die Zahlen aus den USA waren extrem gering, aber.
So, ich weiß nicht, fünftausend in zwanzig Millionen oder sowas ja.
Aber nichtsdestotrotz äh ja, es finde ich, halte ich das eben auch noch für einen etwas unterbeleuchtetes Thema,
Thema nämlich Zusammenhang, Impfung und Alter.
Plus ähm das äh ja möglicherweise äh den Zusammenhang.
Ähm bei älteren Leuten das vielleicht nicht ganz so schlau sein könnte,
mit der Zweitimpfung allzu lange zu warten, sondern dass man da vielleicht auch nochmal eine Ausnahme machen sollte, dass man bei älteren vielleicht dann doch den Frühjahr den komplett Schutz gibt. Aber das sind halt alles komplizierte Berechnungen.
Aber ich denke, wir werden uns mit dem Thema auch nochmal ein bisschen äh äh ja also es wird uns sicherlich noch beschäftigen, weil einfach äh.
Ja, wir halt äh irgendwann in Erklärungsnot kommen werden, wenn in vier Wochen halt immer noch tausendfünfhundert Leute die Woche sterben.
Gut, jetzt aber.
Schluss damit. Du hast eine Umfrage auf Twitter gemacht, die so ein paar Votings hatte, die äh zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme eigentlich noch offen sind, aber jetzt glaube ich so zu neunundneunzig Prozent.
Rum sind.
Ja, also morgen irgendwie äh ich habe hatte die dann auf sieben Tage.
Gestellt, die Umfrage und.
War so ein bisschen einfach auch die Reaktion, ich war halt eben tierisch sauer und tierisch pisst über das, was läuft und auch.
Ja ich fand eben das aufgrund der Fakt.
Wenn man sich die anschaut, wie diese Pandemie so verlaufen ist und äh schön heißt die Anatomie des politischen Skandals, wer hat wann was gewusst? Äh so.
Und da habe ich dann eben ja die Pandemiephase so in oder die Pandemie in fünf Phasen zerlegt,
einfach mal und ein paar,
dazu gepackt wie es halt aussah. So zu Beginn dieser Phase und am Ende der Phase und wie viele Leute sich infiziert haben und wie viele gestorben sind in der Phase und auch eben welche,
Beschlüsse, wann, wie getroffen wurden und ja, das findet man dann eben und kann dann.
Darüber.
Abstimmen äh dort, wie man denn jetzt vor dem Hintergrund ja, all dieser auch Informationen oder wie's wie's gelaufen ist, denn,
jeweilige Reaktion oder das Verhalten der Politik in dieser äh Phase zu bewerten.
Und.
Anlass war auch so ein bisschen dieser Gedenktag da, wo der Pandemie, wo der, wo der Opfer der Pandemie gedacht wurde, so mit Gottesdiensten und Politik und alles tut uns sehr schrecklich leid und so. Und.
Äh so, ich habe dann auch gesagt, nicht jeder Politiker hat sich jetzt gleich,
Verhalten, aber am Ende kann man trotzdem bewerten, was hinten rausgekommen ist und äh ja und ich fand halt so auch den Luktus aus der Politik so nach ein bisschen.
Ja für nichts, so wir haben unser Bestes getan äh.
In Gänze so nicht haltbar und wollte halt wissen, äh wie sehen das denn jetzt alle anderen Leute? Bin ich da irgendwie nur zu streng äh vielleicht grade und deswegen habe ich mir so ein Benutungschema ausgedacht.
Und äh so die aber weil Twitter halt nur vier Möglichkeiten äh zulässt, muss ich mich auf vier äh beschränken und deswegen tadellos.
Das höchste Lob ist die beste Zensur, die man vergeben konnte, akzeptabel ist die zweitbeste, so bedeutet, könnte besser sein, aber ja.
Verzeihen euch.
Ungenügend äh definiert als, dass es nicht annähernd den Anforderungen entspricht und weit unter dem Potential.
Was da war und dann noch die Kategorie unverzeihlich
So, also was äh auch schon natürlich eine moralische
Bewertung ist äh und ich so definiert habe als das als wieder besseres Wissen gehandelt wurde, dass ein katastrophales Ergebnis eingetreten ist und dass die Leute eigentlich eine schwere moralische Schuld.
Auf sich geladen haben. Ja.
Aber du fragst natürlich nicht, aus welchen Gründen die das finden.
Nicht bei jedem einzelnen, aber am Ende da kommen wir auch noch zu, hab ich dann gefragt, ja,
ist das eigentlich aus der Perspektive grundsätzlich, also wie viele der Leute,
sind der Meinung, das hätte mehr getan werden müssen und andere, was das halt weniger getan werden müssen. Es ergibt sich halt auch aus den Kommentaren, aber äh ja.
Und äh wenn wir da mal einfach schnell einsteigen so mhm so in der ersten Welle äh.
So haben, hat einen Viertel, vierundzwanzig Komma sechs Prozent gesagt, tadellos. Ja? Äh die Mehrheit äh dreiundsechzig Prozent sagt akzeptabel.
So, also mit den Worten, ja okay, hätte besser laufen können, aber unterm Strich äh.
Sind wir euch nicht böse. So und nur.
Sieben Komma sieben Prozent haben die für ungenügend gehalten und vier Komma vier Prozent für unverzeilich ja? Also man sieht dann auch schon, dass die Leute grundsätzlich also der,
Zahl derer, die da wirklich sehr strenge Maßstäbe anlegen, nach dem Motto, ist alles Scheiße, ne, so ist doch äh eher nicht so groß bei denen, die sich hier jetzt beteiligt.
Haben und ich finde, ja, die deckt sich auch ganz gut,
so mit meiner Einschätzung und ich glaube, also da.
Hätte man, also wir hätten noch ein, zwei Wochen früher äh loslegen können, aber im Großen und Ganzen,
So wurde das dann nachdem sie erstmal losging bei The Book äh exerziert und es war dann auch erfolgreich und wir sind dann,
innerhalb von sechs, acht Wochen hatten wir eigentlich die erste Welle besiegt,
warnen nicht mehr weit von entfernt, die Inzidenz lag bei zwei Komma sechs bundesweit und ähm ja äh war ein Drittel der Landkreise war Corona frei.
Das war das Ergebnis. Äh so die Bilanz der der ersten Welle eben waren hundertdreiundachtzigtausend.
Fälle und achttausendsechshundertsechsundvierzig Todesfälle und so die Behandlungskosten waren ungefähr hundertdreiundachtzig Millionen in der Phase und.
Ähm ja und Lockerungen gab's halt am vierten Mai, also wenn wir.
Bei einer Inzidenz von sieben pro hunderttausend, ja nur zum Vergleich, also in der in einer Woche sind wir beim vierten Mai, da waren wir vor einem Jahr,
nach der ersten Welle schon auf sieben runter und am siebzehnten Mai konnte halt die Gastronomie öffnen im letzten Jahr bei einer Inzidenz von fünf Komma fünf und dann im Juni wurden halt.
Kontaktbeschränkungen fast komplett aufgehoben bei einer Inzidenz von zwei Komma acht.
Also ja äh man sagen Inzidenzen runter, es wurde vorsichtig gelockert und es war auch äh ja, dann,
erstmal okay. Also beim, wenn man dann die zweite Phase war halt der Sommer. Hm.
So vom sechzehnten Juni dann bis zum dreißigsten September habe ich die einfach mal definiert. Das war so diese
wo auch viele in den Urlaub gefahren sind, aber es dümpelte halt so rum, beziehungsweise stieg halt nur ganz, ganz langsam, kontinuierlich, fiel dann wieder zwischendurch
Ja, aber es war halt dann doch leider äh
eben haben wir nicht die die sagen, haben wir's dann nicht mehr auf null runtergefahren, beziehungsweise haben nicht aufgepasst, dass wir dann.
Eben viel dann wieder reimportiert haben und das wirkte sich eben aus, dass wir dann nochmal hundertfünfunddreißigtausend Fälle hatten im Sommer. Was ja.
Sich doch äh äh leppert, aber das hat dann die Alten nicht ganz so schlimm getroffen. Es war nur.
Neunhundertachtundfünfzig äh neue Todesfälle in.
Der äh Sommerzeit. Aber äh doch eben im Jahr hundertfünfunddreißigtausend Fälle und vor allen Dingen gemessen. Er hatte damals noch,
Ich gedacht, okay, das, was die in Wuhan können, das können wir eigentlich auch.
Und die sind dann ja irgendwann bei achtzigtausend äh äh vorausgelaufen in, in, in China.
Und da dachte ich, ja, also das kriegen wir vielleicht sogar besser hin, aber wir haben's halt schlechter hingekriegt. So, auf jeden Fall die zweite Phase.
Wurde jetzt schon nur noch von eins Komma acht Prozent, also der Sommer als tadellos bewertet. Fünfunddreißig Prozent fand's akzeptabel. Aber,
vierundfünfzig Komma sieben Prozent fand's ungenügend und unverzeilich nur achteinhalb Prozent, also haben gesagt, okay, Sommer,
ist zwar jetzt leider.
Nicht ganz so gut gelaufen, wie jetzt die erste Welle, das ist die Sicht, aber so hm ja.
Irgendwie werfen wir euch da jetzt noch keine Schuld
vor, also die, ich sage mal, die tausend Toten und die hundertfünfunddreißigtausend Infizierten und die hundertfünfunddreißig Millionen äh war jetzt keine
Performance, aber äh ja.
Dann kommt Phase drei. So die zweite Welle und der Lockdown äh light,
Prinzip hier die Phase drei, habe ich gesagt, okay, zehnte Oktober ähm war so der Tag, da hatte sich die Inzidenz äh zu dem Zeitpunkt in elf Tagen,
auf dreißig von hunderttausend verdoppelt und der R-Wert lag bei eins Komma drei.
Das heißt, das war für mich so der Zeitpunkt, den ich halt ausgemacht habe für okay. Ähm da hätten.
Dem Zeitpunkt am zehnten Oktober lagen alle Informationen vor, welchen Weg das nehmen wird.
Man wusste äh ja, äh der Herbst ist da. So, ich meine, Oktober ist ja auch schon mal, ja, kann man sagen, da ist
das ist jetzt nicht mehr Sommer, ja? Sondern das ist jetzt dann der Herbst und das ist jetzt dann die dritte Welle,
aber ja, dann ging's dann erstmal, hat man eine Woche halt nichts getan.
Und dann am siebzehnten Oktober hat die Bundeskanzlerin dann in ihrem Podcast an die Bevölkerung appelliert.
Inzidenz war bei neunundvierzig mittlerweile nichts passiert. Vierundzwanzigster Oktober.
Bei fünfundachtzig, R bei eins Komma drei vier, Bundeskanzlerin wiederholt ihren Podcast, ja? Am.
Achtundzwanzigsten Oktober endlich bei einer von einhundert und im R von eins Komma vier einigt man sich auf den Lockdown light ab zweiten November.
Der geht dann los bei einer Inzidenz von hundertneunundzwanzig. Der Lockdown light.
Und äh so ein paar eben, ja, was war denn eigentlich der Lockdown light ja ein bisschen Kultur, Gastronomie und Dienstleistungsbetriebe.
Geschlossen, aber im Wesentlichen äh ja Schulen, Kitas groß Einzelhandelsbetriebe blieben halt geöffnet.
Dann wurde am, dann ging das,
nach fünf Wochen weiter und am dreizehnten Dezember merkt man, hm, Inzidenz ist jetzt bei hundertneunundsiebzig irgendwie mit dem Leid, scheint ja dann nicht äh scheint ein bisschen zu leid gewesen zu sein, so. Dann hat man.
Eben zum sechzehnten zwölften endlich die Schulen zu schließen, weil also bei den Ferien ein bisschen vorweg zu aber eben beschlossen, dass sieben bis zum zehnten ersten halt zu bleiben.
Und das hat dann dazu geführt, weil wir eben einfach drei Wochen Schulschließungen hatten über Weihnachten äh dass dann
so irgendwann äh ja am sechzehnten Dezember eben gesagt, dieser verschärfte Lockdown begann und wir dann genau Punkt Weihnachten, Heiligabend, vierundzwanzigste Dezember mit zweihundertvierzehn auf dem Höhepunkt der Phase drei angekommen sind,
ja, dann am elften Januar kam halt die Berichte über die Varianten äh beziehungsweise nein.
Die ersten Berichte tatsächlich äh über die UK-Variante kam glaube ich ein bisschen.
Ja am einundzwanzigsten Dezember sagen UK und Südafrika wussten wir halt davon und dann,
Im Januar kam noch mal Brasilien äh dazu am elften Januar und
daraufhin wird dann zum neunzehnten Januar nochmal verschärft so, dabei lagen wir allerdings schon bei wieder bei hundertzweiundvierzig und einem R von null Komma acht acht. Da ging's halt runter, ging's dann mit FFP zwei verschärfte Maskenpflicht und so
und dann ja zum neunten Februar ging dann die,
Öffnungslockerungsdebatte äh los, also Kultusministerkonferenz sagte, fünfzehnte Februar äh so dann gab's.
Ebene Warnung am nächsten Tag von lauter Epidemiologen und die Bundesregierung Warnung vor vor voreiligen Corona Lockerungen
Aber dann passiert halt Bund Ländergipfel und weil man sich nicht einigen konnte äh ja wurden die Schulöffnungen in die Hand der Länder gelegt und gesagt so.
Ja macht doch wie ihr denkt und daraufhin haben die meisten Länder eben den zweiundzwanzigsten Februar als Schulöffnungstermin äh angekündigt und äh ja dann ging's halt nochmal.
Irgendwie eine Woche, ein, zwei Wochen ging's dann nochmal runter. Wir waren dann auf neunundfünfzig Komma sieben
Inzidenz. Also wir hatten schon die fünfzig im Blick und eigentlich waren wir so schon auf einem Korridor, wo wir hätten, ja, normal wie im letzten Jahr eigentlich.
Dann das also Covid runterfahren können. So, aber äh so waren halt ungeduldig und meinte, nee
brauchen wir nicht, wollen wir nicht und hat dann eben Lockerungen debattiert und einfach die Schulen aufgemacht und ja dann halt den Grundstein für die dritte Welle.
Und die Bilanz der Phase drei, äh so die ist eigentlich das Erschütternde, ja. So, wir sind mit.
Einem gesamt, also bis Oktober so in, ich sage mal, neun Monaten ähm fast.
Sieben, acht Monaten gab's eben dreihundertzwanzigtausend Fälle und.
Neuntausendsechshundertvier Todesfälle, so das war, sagen die, wo es dann losgegangen ist und nach der Phase drei hatten wir zwei Millionen und siebenundsechzigtausend neue Fälle, also von ähm eins Komma,
sieben Millionen Fälle, ähm kann man sagen, innerhalb kürzester Zeit und vor allen Dingen,
achtundfünfzigtausendzweihundertsiebenunddreißig neue Todesfälle. Sie dazugekommen sind plus sogar dreiundsechzigtausend, wenn man noch die zwanzig kommt, die sich in der Phase infiziert haben und danach
gestorben sind und allein die Krankenkassen Krankenhauskosten waren so zwei Komma eins Milliarden Euro, aber wird vor allen Dingen eigentlich.
Das tragische sind halt die ganzen ja äh Leute, die die gestorben sind. Und ähm.
Ja und dementsprechend, dass sie offensichtlich nicht nur ich, das äh so gesehen, sondern ja.
Die Phase drei äh haben dann vierundsechzig Komma acht Prozent gesagt. Das war unverzeilich.
Und dreiunddreißig Komma neun Prozent äh sagen ungenügend. So, das heißt, die dritte Phase ist schon was, wo zwei Drittel der Leute
eine moralische Schuld sehen und ein Drittel derer, die hier jetzt abgestimmt haben, ja.
Sehen zumindest dass das ja fachlich und vor dem Hintergrund wie das hätte laufen können trotzdem verkackt.
Akzeptabel hier ins nur für eins Komma zwei Prozent und tadellos null Komma zwei Prozent. So, dass man da durchaus sehen kann, dass die Leute nicht.
Irgendwie abgestimmt haben. So ich kürze es jetzt nochmal ab, dann äh gab's noch die Phase vier, das war so ein kurzes Intermezzo mit den Schul also beginnt mit den Schulöffnungen bis Mitte März hm.
War's dann halt die Trendwende wieder bewirkt hat und eben die dritte äh Welle eingeleitet hat und da finden es sogar noch mehr Leute.
Sechsundachtzig Prozent unverzeilich und dann bei der dritten Welle,
ähm so die dann angefangen hat und dies Ganze,
Hickhack äh eben auch äh ja äh selbst wenn nur Ostern, ich meine mit dem mit diesem Einkaufstag und äh einkaufsfreien Tag oder wie auch immer.
Der dann kam und dann doch nicht und äh ja plus halt dieses ganze Hickhack jetzt zwischen Bund und äh Ländern und,
All das, ja
dreiundneunzig Prozent äh dann jetzt die letzte die dritte Welle für unverzeilich fünf Komma neun Prozent ungenügend und unter ein Prozent ja.
Tadellos oder akzeptabel und interessant ist es aber ich hab dann nochmal 'ne Frage gestellt wie Ihnen jetzt sagen die Leute den Gesamtverlauf und das vorläufige Gesamtergebnis betrachten, da sind Sie dann doch wieder.
Etwas gnädiger, da finden eben nur neunundfünfzig Komma zwei Prozent die Gesamtperformance unverzeilich
und äh neununddreißig Komma sieben ungenügend. So ist also ja, da wird zumindest ein paar Leute haben dann gesagt, äh die die vorher unverzeilich gestimmt haben und sagen, na gut, eben
Gesamtkontext verzeihe ich ihnen dann doch ein bisschen vielleicht. Äh,
und dann äh sagen die die Frage, wer denn eigentlich abgestimmt hat, die hatte ich dann noch hinten äh drangepackt, nämlich mit so, wo man dann sagen konnte, ob man das Corona-Virus persönlich allgemein für
harmlos hält oder für überbewertet hält oder für gefährliche Unterhält oder für gefährlich unterschätzt hält und da ähm.
Ja, äh lang vierundfünfzig Prozent gefährlich unterschätzt und dreiundvierzig Prozent.
Gefährlich. Also wir haben hier ja siebenundneunzig Prozent, würde ich sagen, die teilgenommen haben, sind halt.
Tatsächlich eher Leute, die ja auf der,
sicheren Seite, wie wir befinden. Ich hatte gehofft, dass irgendwie mehr noch aus meiner Bubble äh rausgehen würde und dass ich da irgendwie noch mehr Leute sagen, von der anderen Seite kriege, die das verharmlost oder überbewertet halten, aber die hatten keine Lust.
Sich dann äh zu beteiligen. Ja,
Also so viel dazu und ich denke, das werden wir auch nochmal, also das das äh sage mal, ja.
Zwar jetzt auch dafür, ich sage mal grundsätzlich, verzeihen, ist natürlich schon so eine Sache, das macht man eher für sich und weniger für die anderen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, ja, bin ich nicht zufrieden mit dem
so wie sich da ganz viele Leute grade einfach einen schlanken Fuß machen und sich aus der Affäre ziehen und so tun, als hätten sie das Beste getan, sondern ich bin der Meinung, eigentlich äh ja
dass die Leute eigentlich aus der Politik verschwinden äh sollten und äh ja irgendwie was tun sollen.
Wovon sie was verstehen äh ja und wo sie oder wo sie nicht so viel Schaden anrichten können und nicht irgendwie,
zigtausend äh Leute durch nicht Entscheidungen und durch Fehlentscheidungen äh äh dann äh ja letztlich sterben lassen, völlig unnötig. So und das finde ich, ich meine,
das entzieht sich jetzt 'ne gewichtlichen oder,
juristischen Bewertung, denke ich, weil das ist halt schon so eine so eine politische Geschichte und irgendwie davon jetzt Politiker, die einfach nur
im Rahmen
ihres Mandats als schlechte Politik gemacht haben, egal wie viel Leute dabei draufgehen, so das ist halt, das das wird man
gerichtlich nicht wirklich klären können außer bei ja jetzt ich sag mal wenn's dann,
in Dimensionen von Angriffskriegen und anderen äh Dingen geht, aber grundsätzlich äh finde ich aber,
moralische Schuld ist auf jeden Fall da und äh ja, ich glaube, das ist auch sagt, es gibt da halt bei den Katholiken,
gibt's halt äh da die himmelschreiende Sünde, ähm die dann so heutzutage als schweres soziales Unrecht äh äh gilt.
Und ja, ich finde, ich fand das eigentlich eine.
Ganz gute Bezeichnung für das, was dort passiert ist. Also ich fand's Himmel schreiend und so, ich bin eigentlich schon der Meinung, also dass das dafür gibt's irgendwie,
im Himmel schon mal gar keine Vergebung, da bin ich mir sicher.
Und äh ja und wie wie viele von uns ähm wie jetzt ja das dann ad acta liegen. Wir werden sehen. Äh da bin ich bin ich gespannt,
so ob dann wir einfach, wenn alle durchgeimpft sind, das
ähm peinlich berührt, zur Seite liegen und sagen, naja gut, wir haben jetzt zwar irgendwie hundert oder hundertfünfzigtausend alte Sterben,
lassen, die nicht hätten sterben müssen, aber äh ja, wir können ja schließlich nicht jeden, jedes Leben retten oder wie auch immer. Äh.
Und ähm da bin ich bin ich wirklich wirklich gespannt, wie tief jetzt die Verbitterung äh bei äh ja vielen Leuten gerade sitzt und äh.
Wozu das am Ende des Tages führen wird.
Es gibt da ja eine Bundestagswahl im September,
Auch wenn ich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig sagen kann, wer wer hier sozusagen ähm ohne Fehl äh gewesen ist. Trotz alledem
denke ich mal, ist das die einzige Gelegenheit, wo sich so etwas bahnbrechen kann und das könnte noch ein ganz unterhaltsamer Sommer werden, um zu sehen, wie sie sich da alle winden und versuchen, herauszureden.
So richtig eine Partei nicht so sehr im Sinne von.
Politische Partei, sondern überhaupt so eine Gruppe in der Gesellschaft. Ähm mal für die Wissenschaft vielleicht mal rausnimmt, die sich nichts äh zu schulden hat kommen lassen. Kann ich äh nicht so recht ausmachen.
Also ich, ich denke, was man auf jeden Fall sagen kann, also bei allem ja,
Pandemie äh hin und her und schwieriges, komplexes Thema und äh auch ja, tiefe Eingriffe natürlich in äh,
ja Persönlichkeitsrecht oder Freiheitsrechte äh einfach, das ist äh klar. Äh so, aber bei all dem.
Wenn ich die Performance aus der äh ersten Welle wäre, was halt mindestens der Benchmark,
OK beim ersten Mal da wusste man noch nicht so viel, Unsicherheit war groß da hätte man eigentlich davon ausgehen können, dass wenn man dann dazugelernt hat und ein bisschen Zeit hatte und weiß irgendwie, dass.
Man sich äh und ein halbes Jahr lang vor der Welle im Herbst gewarnt wird, ja und dann sitzen die Leute da.
Und die Kanzlerin machten Podcast und keiner reagiert und die Kanzlerin wiederholten Podcast und ja, also,
so allein diese zwei Wochen.
Das kann man recht gut berechnen, was nur diese zwei Wochen zögern äh und dann natürlich noch die schlechte Maßnahme, so.
Das kann man alles äh wunderbar äh rausrechnen, gegenrechnen. Und das sind egal welches Szenario man nimmt,
ähm sind es zehntausende, die vermeidbar gewesen wären und wenn man eben die erste Welle als Benchmark nimmt,
achttausend Tote in der ersten Welle.
Sagen, gut die zweite war jetzt, wäre jetzt eine längere Winterphase gewesen und so, aber auf der anderen Seite Vorbereitung und äh wir wissen, wie's geht und genug Masken und so hätte man sagen können, sollte es hätte,
die dritte Welle ungefähr bestenfalls in der selben Größenordnung ablaufen. Man kann da auch auf andere Länder gucken,
so wie das dort gelaufen ist, die jetzt auch nicht perfekt waren, aber ähm ja. Einzige, wo man dankbar sein kann für, ist, dass dann doch.
Es nicht so ganz extrem nach oben gegangen ist, also schlimmer geht immer so. Wir hätten halt auch Tschechien oder Belgien, andere Länder imolieren können, aber so unterm Strich, wenn man sich anguckt, äh so im Ranking.
Nach der ersten Welle aus und wie sah es nach der zweiten äh Welle aus? Kann man sagen, hat Deutschland viele Länder, über die wir in der ersten Welle gelacht haben, äh einfach mal überholt.
So in äh der Gesamtzahl der Opfer an anteilig an der Bevölkerung. Also man kann sich ich finde die Politik,
hat keinen Rückzugsort bei der dritten Welle, also für mich keine Entschuldigung. Für mich ist es nicht entschuldbar
was da passiert ist, ja? Sie wussten es, so sie hatten genug Zeit, sich vorzubereiten, so sie haben's nicht getan und äh.
Sechzigtausend Leute sind gestorben. So und ich äh ja, ich finde, das ist eben ein Unrecht, wie gesagt, diese
himmelschreiende Sünde und äh ich finde, davon äh ja, also dafür also wenn's wenn's eine Hölle gäbe, so, was ich nicht glaube, aber finde ich, wäre das der richtige Platz. Äh für viele dieser Leute.
Na dann schauen wir mal, wo wo die sich am Ende dieses Jahres so befinden. Ja, das äh könnt ihr nochmal ganz interessant werden.
Jetzt müssen wir aber wirklich ein Ende finden nach diesen schwermütigen Rückblick.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen du, es ist äh also ich ich glaube, es war zu merken, dass mich das halt schon äh nach wie vor, also.
Beschäftigt so und dass ich damit noch nicht abgeschlossen habe und ich hoffe, dass vielen Leuten oder ich das Gefühl habe, dass es vielen Leuten ähnlich geht so, aber nichtsdestotrotz äh wie gesagt ähm.
Sollte man damit jetzt auch abgeschlossen haben, wo das Ganze ja eigentlich auch alles noch irgendwo läuft. So, ich meine, wir wissen ja noch nicht mal, wie lange wir jetzt mit dieser dritten Welle uns noch beschäftigen müssen, weil noch wälzt sie ja vor sich hin. Wir wissen nicht genau,
wir jetzt hier alle noch auf Impfung warten und bis wir da sozusagen kritische Bereiche,
durchbringen. So oder so ist klar, ein, zwei Monate wird uns das mindestens alles noch sehr aktiv beschäftigen. Und es ist natürlich klar und offensichtlich, dass wir.
Der Politik an der Stelle jetzt auch nicht mehr viel zu erwarten haben. Also das das habe ich schon vor einem Monat äh als diese ganze,
Osternsache war und dieses ganze wir beschließen jetzt mal nix und.
Alle haben geschrien und die Wissenschaft hat alles rausgelassen, was irgendwie war, halt wirklich die maximale Eskalationsstufe und hat sich da einen großen Briefen zusammengestellt, hat gesagt, so jetzt muss aber wirklich was geschehen,
einzige, was ich in dem Moment für möglich gehalten habe, war, dass jetzt der Lockdown endlich kommt. Und es kam nichts. Es kam einfach.
Gar nichts. Es kam nur heiße Luft und es hält
bis heute an. Und deswegen kann man das, glaube ich, auch einfach mal vergessen. Also das ist einfach, es ist von der Politik nichts mehr zu erwarten, alle Verbesserungen, die jetzt kommen werden, sind eigentlich die Disziplin der Gesellschaft selbst,
weil sie's einfach einsieht und besser versteht mittlerweile, als die Leute, die uns eigentlich da äh führen und leiten sollen, das aber nicht tun.
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer und dementsprechend muss man jetzt einfach zusehen, dass man die äh Gelegenheit der Impfung beim Schöpfer ergreift, möglichst schnell sich da äh einreiht, wenn man sich einreihen kann und dann äh,
Werden wir Verbesserungen davon sehen und vielleicht ist so ein bisschen Restsommer noch zu retten.
Ja, also ich.
Jetzt mal ein Versuch auf einen positiven Ausblick zu.
Sie ist auch so sagen äh also positiv ist äh sicher, dass äh einfach der R-Wert aktuell bei eins liegt.
So. Das heißt, wir sind jetzt gerade nicht.
Starken Wachstumsphase drin und werden sehen in welche Richtung sich das wendet,
ich denke ähm dass jetzt auch durchaus die Bundesnotbremse, die.
Zwar eigentlich ja äh äh furchtbar ist und Fortschreibung von hochinzidenz Politik, aber sie,
vermeidet halt sehr wahrscheinlich des des Gesundheitssystem komplett zusammenbricht, also das zumindest, dass es,
sagen, in dem Zusammenhang, so,
wird die ganz große Katastrophe jetzt aus äh bleiben und äh
die Maßnahmen werden eben so nivellierenden Effekt haben,
das kann man auch schon teilweise sehen. Das heißt, die Kreise mit wirklich extrem hohen Inziden werden jetzt runtergehen und
dafür werden aber welche mit niedrigeren Inziden halt anziehen, das heißt Band wird ein bisschen schmaler,
werden und in dem Zusammenhang ja hoffentlich äh äh zumindest jetzt kein allzu großer äh Anstieg mehr. Aber.
Wann wir uns entspannen können.
Mindestens zwei Monate noch, nach allem, was ich sehe und äh wann genau,
kann keiner sagen, dass mal in zwei Wochen würde ich sagen, können wir ein bisschen mehr sagen, wenn wir sehen, wie sich das denn mit den Schulen
ausgewirkt hat und wie die Reaktionen dann tatsächlich waren äh in der Altersgruppe. Aber ja, also ich sage mal, verhaltener Optimismus, aber äh so,
So entspannt wie vor einem Jahr, wird's jetzt erstmal nicht.
Aber dann hoffentlich vielleicht kriegen wir einen netten, warmen Herbst oder so, den wir noch äh nett Sachen machen können und ich kann mir dann auch noch ein bisschen reisen.
Ja, den kriegen wir bestimmt. Das nächste Thema, Klimawandel äh steht ja auch schon an. Ich sehe schon irgendwie nach Corona Wickli kann ich wahrscheinlich hier auch nochmal Klima machen,
mal gucken. Pavel, jetzt packen wir es äh ein. Äh auch wenn wir bestimmte Dinge erst in zwei Wochen äh vorhersagen können.
Könnt ihr auch nächste Woche wieder zuhören. So ist ja nicht, ne? Denn dann gibt's das nächste Corona-Wikli.
Es gibt noch haufenweise Dinge, die wir jetzt heute nicht geschafft haben und die kommen dann nächste Woche dran.
Richtig, äh das das Backlock ist schon äh relativ groß, aber wir mussten jetzt hier mal ein bisschen ausholen. Äh insofern machen wir es jetzt kurz und äh knapp, wünschen euch noch ein schönes Wochenende oder wann auch immer ihr diese Sendung gehört habt. Äh bleibt gesund, bleibt.
Locker, bleibt positiv und wir hören uns dann nächste Woche.
Macht's gut, tschüss.